hey everyone
i welcome you all to this jenkins full
course by simply learn
in this complete course we will learn
everything that we need to know to excel
in jenkins devops
we have mathews chidanad and anuj to
guide us through this journey
we shall begin with having a basic
understanding of devops with a short
animated video
after that we shall dive deeper and
understand what devops is and its
relevance in the present scenario
in this process we shall also learn
about the ci cd pipeline
and how it is important in the process
of automation
finally we shall learn what jenkins is
its relevance
and how we can install it in this
process we will also see several
hands-on demos helping us understand the
entire process
more effectively after we have a fair
amount of knowledge regarding jenkins we
will look at some of the jenkins
interview questions that will increase
your chances
to crack any jenkins interview so
before we begin make sure that you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
don't forget to click on the bell icon
so you never miss an update from simply
learn now
without any further ado let's begin with
our animated introduction
meet tim tim builds a robot in his lab
a climate controlled and pollution-free
environment
once he's done he drops the robot off at
his project partner
mia's house mia takes it out to her
backyard
to ensure that the robot meets the
requirements
but here is where the problem arises the
change in the environment
causes the robot to malfunction mia is
now
really annoyed and she has a lot to
correct and it seems to her
as though tim didn't really do much this
wall between them leaves a poor robot
to bite the dust well what if
we broke this wall tim and miana work
together
in a common space tim develops each
block of functionality of the robot
which is then immediately checked by mia
both are now working simultaneously
instead of waiting on the other to
finish their task
as and when a feature is ready for use
they are put together
to build the final product they develop
a common mindset
and share ideas to further speed up the
process
they use several tools which can
automate every stage
this means that the robot is now ready
sooner with less iterations
and manual work from an organization
perspective
tim would be the developer while mia the
operations
their union is the core of the devops
approach
devops has several stages and set of
tools to automate
each of these stages let's have a look
at these tim first puts down a plan
in terms of software this could mean
deciding on the modules
and the algorithms to use once he has
the plan
he now codes the plan with tools such as
git
tim has a repository for storing all the
codes
and their different versions this is
called version control
next this code is fetched and made
executable
this is the build stage tools such as
gradle and maven will sort this out
now before deployment the product is
tested
to catch any bugs the most popular tool
automating testing
is selenium once the products are tested
mia must deploy it the deployed product
is then continuously configured to the
desired state
ansible puppet and docker are some of
the most common tools used that
automate these stages now every product
is continuously monitored in its working
environment
nagios is one such tool that automates
this space
and the feedback is fed back to the
planning stage
and finally we have the core of the
devops life cycle
the integration stage tools such as
jenkins
is responsible for sending the code for
build
and test if the code passes the tests
it's further sent for deployment this is
called continuous integration
giants such as amazon netflix target
xc and walmart have all adopted devops
and seen a considerable increase in
delivery and quality
in 2014 an hour of downtime for netflix
would cost 200 000 dollars
it became absolutely crucial that
netflix prepared themselves for
any sort of failure and so they took to
the devops approach
and implemented it in the most unique
way
they developed a tool called simeon army
this tool created failures and
automatically deployed them in an
environment
that did not affect the users the team
would troubleshoot these failures
and this gave them enough experience to
deal with
any degree of collapse with everything
being automated
and happening simultaneously
organizations can now deliver
at a much faster pace so considering the
benefits of devops and its divergence
from the traditional methods would
devops be the future
hello this is matthew with simply learn
and today we're going to go through and
introduce you
to devops we're going to go through a
number of key
elements today the first two will be
reviewing
models that you're already probably
using for delivering solutions into your
company
and the most popular one is waterfall
followed by agile then we'll look at
devops and how devops differs from the
two models and how it also borrows and
leverages the best of those models
we'll go through each of the phases that
are used in typical devops delivery
and then the tools used within those
phases to really
improve the efficiencies within devops
finally we'll summarize the advantages
that devops brings to you and your teams
so let's go through waterfall so
waterfall is a traditional
delivery model that's been used for many
decades for delivering
solutions not just i.t solutions and
digital solutions but
even way before that it has its history
that goes back
to world war ii so waterfall is a model
that is used to capture requirements and
then cascade each
key deliverable through a series of
different
stage gates that is used for building
out the solution
so let's take you through each of those
stage gates
the first that you may have done is
requirements analysis and this is where
you sit down with the actual client and
you understand
specifically what they actually do and
what they're looking for
in the software that you're going to
build and then from that
requirements analysis you'll build out a
project planning so you have an
understanding of what the level of work
is needed to be able to
be successful in delivering the solution
after that
you've got your plan then you start
doing the development and that means
that the programmers start
coding out their solution they build out
their applications to build out
the websites and this can take weeks or
even months to actually do
all the work when you've done your
coding and development then you send it
to another group that does
testing and they'll do full regression
testing of your application against
the systems and databases that integrate
with your application
you'll test it against the actual code
you'll do manual testing you do ui
testing and then after you've delivered
the solution you go into maintenance
mode which is just kind of making sure
that the application keeps working
there's any security risks that you
address those security risks
the problem you have though is that
there are some challenges however that
you have with the waterfall
model the cascading deliveries and those
complete and separated stage gates means
that it's very
difficult for any new requirements from
the client
to be integrated into the project so if
a client comes back
and if the project has been running for
six months and they've gone hey
we need to change something that means
that we have to almost restart the whole
project it's very expensive
and it's very time consuming also if you
spend
weeks and months away from your client
and you deliver a solution
that they are only just going to see
after you spend a lot of time
working on it they could be pointing out
things that are in the actual final
application that they don't want
or are not implemented correctly or lead
to just
general unhappiness the challenge you
then have is if you want to
add back in the client's feedback to
restart the whole waterfall cycle again
so the client will come back to you with
a list of changes
and then you go back and you have to
start your programming and you have to
then start
your testing process again and just
you're really adding in lots of
additional time
into the project so using waterfall
model companies have soon come to
realize that you know the clients just
aren't able to get their feedback in
quickly effectively it's very expensive
to make changes once the teams have
started working
and the requirement in today's digital
world is that solutions
simply must be delivered faster
and this has led for a specific change
in
agile and we start implementing the
agile model
so the agile model allows programmers to
create prototypes and get those
prototypes to the client
with the requirements faster and the
client is able to then send the
requirements
back to the programmer with feedback
this allows us to create what we call a
feedback
loop where we're able to get information
to the client and the client can get
back
to the development team much faster
typically when we're actually going
through this process we're looking at
the engagement cycle being about two
weeks and so
it's much faster than the traditional
waterfall approach
and so we can look at each feedback loop
as comprising of
four key elements we have the planning
where we actually sit down
with the client and understand what
they're looking for we then have
coding and testing that is building out
the
code and the solution that is needed for
the client and then we review
with the client the changes that have
happened but we do all this in a much
tighter cycle that we call
a sprint and that typically a sprint
will last for about
two weeks some companies run sprints
every week some run every four weeks
it's up to you as a team
to decide how long you want to actually
run a sprint
but typically it's two weeks and so
every two weeks
the client is able to provide feedback
into
that loop and so you were able to move
quickly through
iterations and so if we get to the end
of sprint two
and the client says hey you know what we
need to make a change you can make those
changes quickly and effectively
for sprint three what we have here is a
breakdown
of the ceremonies and the
approach that you bring to agile so
typically what will happen
is that a product leader will build out
a backlog of products and what we call a
product backlog
and this will be just a whole bunch of
different features and they
may be small features or bug fixes all
the way up to
large features that may actually span
over multiple sprints
but when you go through the sprint
planning you want to actually break out
the work that you're doing
so the team has a mixture of small
medium and large solutions that they can
actually implement
successfully into their sprint plan and
then
once you actually start running your
sprint again it's a two-week activity
you meet every single day to with the
actual sprint team
to ensure that everybody is staying on
track and if there's any blockers
that those blockers are being addressed
effectively and immediately
the goal at the end of the two weeks is
to have a deliverable product that you
can put in front of the customer and the
customer can then do a review
the key advantages you have of running a
sprint with agile is that the client
requirements are better understood
because the client is really
integrated into the scrum team they're
there
all the time and the product is
delivered much faster than with a
traditional
waterfall model you're delivering
features at the end of each
sprint versus waiting weeks months or in
some cases
years for a waterfall project to be
completed
however there are also some distinct
disadvantages
the product itself really doesn't get
tested in a production environment it's
only been tested on the developer
computers
and it's really hard when you're
actually running agile for the sprint
team
to actually build out a solution easily
and effectively
on their computers to mimic the
production environment
and the developers and the operations
team
are running in separate silos so you
have your development team
running their sprint and actually
working to build
out the features but then when they're
done at the end of their sprint and they
want to do a release
they kind of fling it over the wall at
the operations team and then it's the
operations
team job to actually install the
software and make sure that the
environment
is running in a stable fashion that is
really difficult to do when you have the
two teams
really not working together so here we
have is a breakdown
of that process with the developers
submitting their work to the operations
team for deployment
and then the operations team may submit
their work
to the production servers but what if
there is an error what if there was a
setup configuration error with the
developers test environment that doesn't
match the production environment
there may be a dependency that isn't
there there may be a link
to an api that doesn't exist in
production
and so you have these challenges that
the operations team
are constantly faced with and their
challenge is that they don't know how
the code works
so this is where devops really comes in
and let's dig into how devops which is
developers and operators
working together is the key for
successful
continuous delivery so devops is as an
evolution of the agile model the agile
model really is great
for gathering requirements and for
developing and testing
out your solutions and what we want to
be able to do is
kind of address that challenge and that
gap between the ops team and the dev
team
and so with devops what we're doing is
bringing together the operations team
and the development team
into a single team and they are able to
then
work more seamlessly together because
they are integrated to be able to build
out solutions that are being tested in a
production-like environment
so that when we actually deploy we know
that the code itself will work
the operations team is then able to
focus on what they're really good at
which is analyzing the production
environment and being able to provide
feedback to the developers on what is
being successful
so we're able to make adjustments in our
code that it's based on
data so let's step through the different
phases of a devops team so typically
you'll see that the devops team
will actually have eight phases now this
is somewhat similar
to agile and what i'd like to point out
at time is that again
agile and devops are very closely
related
that agile and devops are closely
related
delivery models that you can use with
devops it's really just
extending that model with the key phases
that we have here so let's step through
each of these key phases
so the first phase is planning and this
is where we actually sit down
with a business team and we go through
and understand what their goals are
the second stage is as you can imagine
and this is where it's all very similar
to agile
is that the coders actually start coding
but they typically they'll start using
tools such as
git which is a distributed version
control
software it makes it easier for
developers to all be working
on the same code base rather than bits
of the code that
is rather than them working on bits of
the code that they
are responsible for so the goal with
using tools such as git
is that each developer always has the
current and latest version of the code
you then use tools such as mavin and
gradle
as a way to consistently build out your
environment
and then we also use tools to actually
automate our testing now what's
interesting is when we use tools like
selenium and junit is that we're moving
into a world where our testing is
scripted
the same as our build environment and
the same as using our get environment we
can
start scripting out these environments
and so we actually have
scripted production environments that
we're moving towards
jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools
and another pointer here is that the
tools that we're listing here these are
all
open source tools these are tools that
any team can start
using we want to have tools that control
and manage the deployment
of code into the production environments
and then finally
tools such as ansible and chef will
actually operate and manage those
production environments so that when
code comes to them
that that code is compliant with the
production environment so that when
the code is then deployed to the many
different production servers that
the expected results of those servers
which is you want them to continue
running
is received and then finally you monitor
the entire
environment so you can actually zero in
on spikes and issues
that are relevant to either the code or
changing consumer
habits on the site so let's step through
some of those tools that we have
in the devops environment so here we
have is a breakdown
of the devops tools that we have and
again
one of the things i want to point out is
that these tools are open source
tools there are also many other tools
this is just really a selection of some
of the more popular tools that are being
used but it's quite likely that you're
already using some of these tools today
you may already be using jenkins you may
already be using
git but some of the other tools really
help you create a fully scriptable
environment so that
you can actually start scripting out
your entire
dev ops tool set this really helps when
it comes to
speeding up your delivery because the
more you can actually
script out of the work that you're doing
the more effective you can be
at running automation against those
scripts and
the more effective you can be at having
a consistent experience
so let's step through this devops
process so we go through and we have our
continuous delivery which is
our plan code build and test environment
so what happens if you want to make a
release well the first thing you want to
do is send
out your files to the build environment
and you want to be able to
test the code that you've been created
because we're scripting
everything in our code from the actual
unit testing being done
to the all the way through to the
production environment because we're
testing all of that
we can very quickly identify whether or
not there are any defects within the
code if there are defects we can
send that code right back to the
developer with a message saying
what the defect is and the developer can
then fix
that with information that is real on
the
either the code or the production
environment
if however your code passes the the
scripting test
it can then be deployed and once it's
out to
deployment you can then start monitoring
that environment
what this provides you is the
opportunity to
speed up your delivery so you go from
the waterfall model
which is weeks months or even years
between releases
to agile which is two weeks or four
weeks depending on your
sprint cadence to where you are today
with devops where you can actually be
doing multiple releases
every single day so there are some
significant advantages
and there are companies out there that
are really
zeroing in on those advantages if we
take
any one of these companies such as
google
google any given day will actually
process
50 to 100 new releases on their website
through their devops teams in fact they
have some great videos on youtube
that you can find out on how their dev
op teams work
netflix is also a similar environment
now what's interesting with netflix is
that netflix have
really fully embraced devops within
their development team and so they have
a devops team
and netflix is a completely digital
company so
they have software on phones on smart
tvs
on computers and on websites
interestingly though
the devops team for netflix is only 70
people
and when you consider that a third of
all internet traffic on any given day
is from netflix it's really a reflection
on how effective
devops can be when you can actually
manage that entire
business with just 70 people so there
are some key advantages that devops has
it's the actual time to create and
deliver software is dramatically reduced
particularly compared to waterfall
complexity and maintenance is also
reduced because you're automating
and scripting out your entire
environment and you're improving the
communication between all your teams
so teams don't feel like they're in
separate silos but that are actually
working cohesively together
and that there is continuous integration
and continuous delivery
so that your consumer your customer is
constantly
being delighted welcome everyone to this
topic on continuous
integration delivery and deployment so
this topic by simply learn is going to
explain you that what exactly is
all about the continuous integration
process continuous deployment
and continuous delivery so let's talk
about these concepts one by one
so continuous integration is in kind of
a process which is which comes up in the
first part
right so first the continuous
integrations comes into the picture then
the continuous delivery and the
deployment comes
into the part so the main important
component or the main
task which we primarily perform in the
continuous integration
is all about the build automations test
executions
and merging in various branches so it's
nothing but the integration of the
source code
from the each and individual developers
machines to a shared location
which we often call it as an kind of a
version control system
so continuous integration is integrating
the source code into the shared
repositories
and then depending on the order triggers
once the changes are checked into the
version control system
the automated build test cases all these
executions can really happen
now in the build process and the test
cases automation
it's going to validate that how the
source code is really working
uh how the compilation is going on how
the test cases are getting executed
so all these things are getting
validated during the execution of these
things
now once the continuous integration is
successful we can not assure
give a hundred percent surety that the
code base is working fine
because it's just taking care of the
compilation and the test cases
there could be a possibility that some
kind of errors may also come up into the
production environment
because those test cases or those
scenarios are not being covered in the
test cases
so test cases are very important aspect
over here because
it's giving us the authority whether we
need to proceed further or we need to
halt there itself
so after the continuous integration the
next process which comes into the
picture is the automatic
release to the repository over here
right so it's just
a kind of a mechanism where we will be
releasing the source code to the
artifacts we are uploading the artifacts
particular component
so that kind of automation is available
but that is also
happening when we are saying that yes
the test cases execution is successful
and we have to proceed further and at
the end it's nothing but the automated
deployment to the production environment
which we call it as an kind of
continuous deployment
over here so these are the overall
process which we are looking forward
so that we will be able to have an
end-to-end automations going
on over here with the help of ci cd
automations
now continuous indications again the
build test
merge these are the different options
which we do
so continuous integration is a kind of a
process a kind of a development process
which is being
used by most of the development teams
nowadays that
eventually enables the developers to
merge their source code
uh whatever the changes whatever the
modifications they are doing they
can a particular uh you know like merge
their source code from their local
systems to the centralized repository
so that after that with the help of ci
tools we can actually have the
build automations and the test cases
automation there so this is the reason
why we
prefer the continuous integration
process because it depends on the basis
of our modifications that how the whole
build and test cases
automations can really happen here now
continuous integration is considered as
a very important process because of the
various reasons
let's talk about those reasons one by
one the very first one is that it
avoids the merge conflicts because if we
frequently
uh sync back our source code from our
systems to the shared repository
and the same thing can be done by other
developers also so eventually it
definitely helps the different
developers to collaborate their source
code into a single
shared repository and that can really
help you to avoid the merge conflict
situations because
you are always going to work on the
latest source code so
the scope of merge conflicts is not
going to be there
it also helps us to decrease the need of
the code review because
we are just doing the uh collaboration
frequently so
uh we don't require any person to be
sitting there and you know have
uh to perform a kind of a heavy duty uh
code review because
uh that is something which we can easily
manage and we can work with that so code
review
uh is something which we can easily
decrease with the help of this
continuous integration
process uh it also speeds up the
development process
yes definitely because the developers
can easily collaborate with each other
so from collaboration perspective also
it's beneficial for us to do and that
can really help us to see that how
easily we can integrate our source code
and that differs or that basically helps
us to go for the
overall mechanism and you know going for
and perfect automation process over here
so it also increases the overall
development process which needs to be
implemented
during the ci process next it
also reduce the product backlog because
we are doing our changes frequently into
the repositories
so uh any kind of product backlog which
is there which is pending from long
that is also can be managed easily
because it's keep on you know reduce
there so we keep we keep on
implementing our changes we keep on
implementing merging us
particular changes to the share
repository so that reduces the amount of
backlog which is available now next
thing is
the continuous delivery which is an
automatic release to the repositories
here
so what exactly is in continuous
delivery all about so continuous
delivery is a kind of a practice that
refers to the
particular building testing delivering
improvements to the software code
so the important part of continuous
delivery is that the code is always in
the deployable state
so we are saying that we are done with
the delivery we are ready with the
delivery
and whichever environment whichever uh
particular server you want us to deploy
we are ready to do that so that is where
we call it as in continuous delivery so
we have our artifacts ready
and whenever is desired whenever we feel
that we want to do the deployments we
want to proceed further
we will be able to do that with the help
of this process
so it's in kind of an end-to-end process
you do the belts
you do the test cases executions once
the test case execution is done once the
testing is done
then you create an artifacts you create
a particular bar files
java files er files whatever the
artifacts we have we prepare that
artifacts
and then we deliver it to a specific
environment we say that yes
let's go with the delivery let's make it
into a particular state where we will be
able to deploy
to pretty much any environment which we
feel as such over here
so that's a real beauty about the
continuous delivery where we can
actually deliver it to whatever
environment we feel
we want to deliver now
continuous delivery is uh also something
which is a very important concept for
most of the organizations
so each and every organizations are
actually looking forward
to invest in this one for a variety of
reasons because
uh it's something where we can invest
some of our particular efforts
budget money a lot of things are there
but the kind of benefits which we get in
the
return that's what we are going to talk
about over here as such
so let's go with that so it provides the
higher quality of products
yes the efforts are there yes the
investment is also there
but in the return the prime the very
important concept or very important
thing which we get
is the high quality of products here so
the kind of quality which we are getting
with this one
is quite high and that's the biggest
benefit which we get when we talk about
any kind of continuous integration
continuous delivery
or continuous deployment here so the
quality is always
top notch when we work of these
particular processes
it also helps us to go for a quicker and
less risky releases
so that's another benefit which we get
this process customers are also
satisfied because they feel that yes we
are going with this uh particular
automated process um within you know few
days we are getting the deliveries
uh we don't have to wait for months for
getting our delivery so that's the
biggest benefit
which a customer usually gets when he
talks about the continuous delivery
and it's more efficiency is there and
the cost of fitness of the team also so
from the cost
and from the particular efficiency
all those parameters are fully fulfilled
when we talk about the continuous
delivery so this process delivers
a lot of benefits which can eventually
help us to go for an perfect high
quality product which we can develop
as such over here now the next thing is
the continuous deployment which is an
automatic deployment to the production
environment
so let's see that what exactly is
incontinence deployment all about here
so continuous deployment refers to the
final stage
in the pipeline so which means that we
are not only preparing our artifacts we
are not only doing the
uh particular compilations or test cases
executions
we are actually going one step ahead and
this one step ahead is nothing but the
deployment to the production environment
so this is what we are typically doing
when we talk about the continuous
deployment over here that we are going
to one step ahead and that's where we
are going for the
deployment of our particular artifact so
we are deploying to the production
environment
so that our changes whatever the changes
we are trying to do we are trying to
make
that should be deployed to the
production environment right
now so continuous deployment again is
can be deployed to
a higher whatever the organizations want
to feel
or want to deploy they can actually go
with that and there are a lot of
benefits actually which we get when we
talk about the continuous deployment
so let's see about all these particular
deployments one by one so first of all
the faster development of the products
is there so we are looking forward that
when we are going for the automations
when we are going for this deployment
so it we get a kind of a faster uh you
know development process which is there
so
the products are getting developed very
quickly very fast that's the biggest
benefit which you are getting when we
talk about this continuous deployment
here
and it's less risky releases also there
and it's easy to fix problems
whatever the automations we are feeling
we are trying to perform that can
definitely help us to go that how we can
automate and how we can
go for these particular releases over
here so these are releases are very
less risky because we are doing all the
things automated there is not much of a
scope which is there for the manual
errors
so usually manual errors is something
which is the biggest uh
problem or which is the biggest risk
when we go for any release but that is
something which is totally
removed with this automation here now it
also helps in continuous improvement in
the quality
so continuously improve quality is also
getting improved as such here
now let's talk about that why exactly as
and we
talk about at the industry level in the
market level also
that the ci cd is one of the best
practices now what is the reason behind
that
why those are known as the best
development and devops practices
as such now continuous integration and
continuous delivery are the best
practices
as they create an effective process the
kind of integration and delivering the
source code
these are the prime things which we need
to take care when we talk about the
development
uh teams over here so they want an
automated process
first of all and they also wanna
streamline process which
can you know take up the things uh which
should not
fail it should be a fail-safe process
mechanism
through which they can release various
kind of changes to the production
environment
because ultimately they are looking
forward for the deployment of their
changes to the production environment
so how they are going to do that that is
where the ci cd or the continuous
integration and continuous
delivery helps on that part and that's
the reason why they can
help the teams the development teams to
go for an
effective process implementations
when we go for these implementations of
these two practices
small call changes can be easily made in
the software course so you don't require
much of the efforts if you are going for
even small changes in the source code
that can also be effectively deployed to
a production environment
in a simple straightforward and easy
mechanism the changes
can go from the developer machines to
the production environment that's the
biggest benefit which we get
due to which we feel that yes these two
processes should be implemented into a
devops platform
right so ca and cd provides continuous
feedback from the customers
and also from the development teams
devops teams
so the increase of transparency is also
something which is
important which is implemented with
these processes here
so the process enables faster release of
the product so we don't have to wait for
months to release the source code there
within a couple of hours within couple
of days we can actually release it to
the production environment
provided we do all these steps like
build compilations
testing development uh validation all
these things will be done in that
duration of time
so the failures can be easily detected
faster
and uh you can easily find out that what
is the problem with the code base what
is the problem that changes
and we can even do the hot fixes now
hotfix says these kind of
ad hoc changes are also can be easily
deployed to production environment
within just a couple of hours there so
that was
a complete summary on what exactly is
the acd
and the prime important concept which we
have
got a proper understanding is that why
these two processes
are really important for our development
process and the only benefit which we
are getting the prime benefit which we
are getting from these processes
implementation
is that we get an effective build
process effective test cases automation
process and automated deployment process
and these processes
when we combine that is something which
we can
use to deliver our source code our
features to the production environment
and eventually to the
end user so that's how the ci cd
automations really works into a devops
environment
hey guys welcome to jenkins pipeline
tutorial by
simply learn my name is chidanan and let
me quickly walk you through the topics
that i plan to cover as a part of this
tutorial at a very high level
i'll be introducing you jenkins and then
get into more details
of the continuous integration process as
most of you are aware
most of the softwares in recent times
are developed
using some or the other kind of agile
practices
and continuous integration is an
important or
key factor in all such agile software
development life cycle
next i'll be looking at the software
delivery pipeline from a perspective of
if someone were to visualize all the
steps that is required from the time
someone gives out a requirement a
software requirement
it gets translated into some sort of a
code and gets tested
may be moved into one of the testing
platforms and then
migrated across or moved across or
propagated across various
environments and then finally put out in
production if
one were to put a value stream mapping
for all these
steps that is involved each of these
steps could translate into a simple job
within jenkins
i will first look at what existed in
jenkins
or rather pre-jenkins 2.0 where we had a
way of
upstream downstream mapping of jobs
there were some plugins that allowed us
to visualize
all the jobs at one shot starting from
the first job that triggered
and then i will get into the most
powerful groovy scripting
that are there in jenkins 2.0 or post
jenkins 2.0
these groovy scripting uses much more
powerful
ways of defining our pipelines there are
two different
ways in which you can write your scripts
one is the scripted one the other one is
declarative one there's very subtle
change or difference between each one of
them
but these gives you a much more flexible
and much more powerful feature
to write complicated pipelines for your
software delivery having said that
most of these topics that i'm going to
discuss will be followed up with a
demo and the source code for most of
these would be on our github repository
all right now as a prerequisite probably
it may be a good idea in case if you
haven't already watched
please watch our previous video wherein
i mentioned
how to install jenkins and how to put up
some sample jobs on our jenkins server
so what exactly is jenkins jenkins is
nothing but
a powerful automation server that is
written in java
and it is a web application which can
also be run
on any web server but what makes jenkins
an ideal choice for a continuous
integration server
jenkins has got wonderful plugins that
allows
it to connect to all kinds of tools
software development
deployment coding build source code kind
of tools
that is what makes jenkins very very
powerful
from a continuous integration
perspective jenkins can connect to
various source code servers and it has
also got plugins
that allows it to build deploy test
all kinds of software artifacts so this
is what makes
jenkins an ideal choice for a continuous
integration server
but mind you for me jenkins is nothing
but a very very powerful
automated server at the heart of it
there's a lot of automation in it but
the powerfulness of jenkins is more so
because of
the tools that it integrates with and
the kind of plugins that it has got
what is continuous integration from a
software development uh life cycle
assuming that the software delivery is
happening in very small sprints
maybe three to four weeks is your
delivery life cycle and there are a
bunch of developers who are located in
different locations
who are working on the same code base on
the same branch
if the code check-ins do not happen
quickly as in
every day if at all developers stagger
their code check-ins into the repository
finding problems at a later stage would
be very costly for the whole project
early detection of any such issues would
be you know quick to resolve and
would not affect your delivery schedules
so as a part of continuous integration
what is requested or what is demanded is
that every developer checks in code
pretty much you know every day as long
as it doesn't break the code
he checks in code pretty much regularly
and at the end of
a day you have an automated server which
kind of wakes up
pulls the latest code so this code has
got the integrations of all the code
bases
that has been checked in by various
developers so it pulls out the code
it builds on a completely different
server
there is the ci server which pulls this
code it builds it it's got
all the tools that is required to
compile it build it and test it
and assuming that you got some good
percentage of test case automation
you're also having a most of your
regression test suites
automated if you're at all there is a
way by which in a couple of hours time
when the team is out
or rather team is sleeping you have
verification that happens
at a very crucial level and then any
breakages even before the team arrives
for the next day
if these are notified to the whole team
members saying an email going out
saying that something got broken most of
the code would be pretty
okay from the perspective of compilation
errors or build errors
it is the functionality and the
regression that the team is worried
about so if these can be automated
test it very very quickly and very very
fast and then
any breakages are detected early during
the day right by the time the next day
people come in
they know what is broken and possibly
they know what code
check-in broke that particular thing and
they can have a quick
stand-up meeting and then they discuss
what broke the code and able to fix it
so this way any problem that could
possibly arise
at a later point in time if at all they
kind of move to the
initial phase of the project any
detection that is early
doesn't really hurt the team so this is
all continuous integration that is about
and jenkins plays
an important role in being the
continuous integration server because
it's got connections to anything and
everything all kinds of tools i mean and
then
it is also got various ways on which
triggering the job which is a part of
its automation strategy
now that we know what is continuous
integration and where does
jenkins come into picture let's look at
the rest of the tasks of our software
development life cycle
so if at all i were to visualize the
kind of steps that is involved
in delivering my software possibly the
continuous integration phase would be
somewhere here
where multiple developers are developing
on that and then we have a little bit of
a stable code that is there that can be
kind of moved across because
i want to go ahead with the particular
build that i have
and then i want to migrate that i want
to propagate that
across various environments so if you
consider the
standard software delivery approach in
the first cycle you just do some minimal
testing
and then you kind of move that to one of
the environments and from there you kick
off more and more tests they could be
integration test they could be
acceptance test they could be
functionality check they could be a
stress test there could be a load test
it could be a system
integration test all kinds of tests that
you can think about
and all the way may be propagating the
build across various environments if
all this can be considered as various
steps the workflow is such that as and
when the build moves
across various phases if there's any
failure of course the build propagation
kind of stops
everyone gets notified but if at all
everything goes well
so your workflow is progressing well and
at the end of the workflow
you eventually have a code which is
pretty much
good to release now mind you i make an
assumption here that
most of your test cases are automated
and you have a good percentage of
coverage
of your test cases but if that is not
the scenario then possibly there are
some
automated tests or checks that may be
required in between
but if the workflow can kind of
accommodate all that as well
you know you can visualize this as the
steps that is required for your software
development
or software delivery lifecycle now in
jenkins the way this kind of translates
is that
each of these tasks can be put out as a
job so now let me quickly
let you know or let me quickly demo what
existed in
preach and kins 2.0 where i could put up
a couple of
jobs and i can connect them using the
upstream downstream linking mechanism
so if there's job one if at all it is a
build and even test cases
if at all that passes successfully job 2
gets triggered
if the job 2 is more about running some
more automated tests
or possibly deploying it to environment
and then kicking off some more test
cases
that would be job too but if the
deployment fails or if some of the other
test cases fail
it would not propagate to the third job
all right so let me
quickly bring up my jenkins instance and
put up some sample jobs and tell you how
to connect that
or rather how could one connect that
using
jenkins 2.0 or pre jenkins 2.0 release
i have now brought up my jenkins
instance and in case
some of you don't know how to install
jenkins or you don't know how to bring
up your jenkins instance
i would strongly recommend that you
watch our previous videos on
simplylearn youtube channel where i've
detailed out the steps that is required
for you to
install jenkins and bring it up so
alright so i brought up my jenkins
instance let me put up few of those
jobs now mind you i'm going to cover the
pre
jenkins 2.0 feature here all right so
let me put up my first job
all right i hope i don't have that job i
say it's a freestyle project
i don't want to change anything i'm
going to put up a very very simple job
here
it's in batch command let's say echo
first job triggered
at right that's my first job
now let me put up my second job
freestyle project
all right that's my second job
all right that's my third job i've got a
very very simple
echo statement in this so it just prints
out the system date and the time in it
all right so i could run these jobs
individually if i want so
let me just check running my third job
so this is what i get
in the console output third job
triggered at date and time oops
let me fix that
right that should fix it let me check my
second job
all right that's my second job all right
so
i've got three jobs now if i were to
link them together or if at all i want
a scenario where after the first job is
successfully run i would like to trigger
my second job
so i will do a small configuration
change in here i would say after this
first job is run
i want to trigger the second job so i
have something called as a
post build action so i can say that
trigger some other jobs from here
so if you see this publish record deploy
all right trigger trigger trigger
trigger let me check the other one
build other projects this is what i
would want to do so after the first job
is done
i want to trigger my second job all
right i would say save this
now let me go back to my second job and
then trigger the third job
after the second job is done
right i will add this post build build
other projects
third job again i'm not really sure if
you guys notice this
there is various configurations as to
when exactly do you want to
trigger the other job and the default
one is trigger only if the build is
stable
so typically this is the configuration
that would need we definitely don't want
the third job to be triggered
in case the second job fails all right
so this is the combination that i want
or this is the choice that i want and i
save this
now i have three of my jobs if you see
this the second job
the upstream job is the first job so let
me check
this kind of a pipeline what i've set
here is a very very simple pipeline so
after my first job gets triggered
if i build this guy right the second job
gets triggered
after the build first job is built so if
i click on the second job
all right so the first job was to get
the second job and
after the second job it is triggering
the third job so this is how
first job second job and third job were
kind of linked but it's pretty hard to
visualize this
as to you know if i need to see one
holistic picture
where after the first job after the
second job after the third job what was
the flow it's not possible for me to
visualize that that's where in
i install a plugin so let me go to
manage plugins
right here i think i already have it
installed for those of you don't have it
installed you can go to the available
button i mean available tab and click on
that the plugin is called
delivery pipeline plugin i already have
it installed in case you don't have it
installed you just go to the available
you click on this and say install
without restart this is the plugin that
i want you to
install all right so now we have that
plugin installed so what i want to do is
after the plugin is installed you see
something like this
so this is where i would create a new
visualization
for the pipeline that i've created so i
would say my
first pipeline or i give a name for my
visualization i
would say yes this upstream downstream
dependencies this is exactly what i want
and there are a bunch of settings here
i'll not look at any of that now what i
want is
i just want to tell this view that you
know the i can give a name for this
i would give it as simply learn pipeline
and what's important is that
i specify what is the first job that
should be picked up as a part of this
pipeline and the final job is optional
because it knows that if the first job
is triggering those other jobs it knows
where to end this whole
life cycle so i define a pipeline and
give a name for my component and
initialize that as my i mean i give it
the first job so i say okay
and there you go this is much better
this gives you a beautiful
visualization of as to what happened
after the first job second job was run
second job if i click on any of these
that will in fact take me to the job all
right there is also one other option
which is
pretty good option in my opinion which
is about
edit view yes this is where it is enable
start of a new pipeline build
let me apply and let me click ok on this
what it gives me
is a way in which i can trigger my whole
pipeline from here
so if i click on this there you see the
first job getting triggered the second
job is still running
the green means it's all run properly
and nicely second one is triggered now
the third one
it's still running all right so this is
the pipeline
that existed prior to jenkins 2.0 this
is pretty decent enough and if you see
there's a one-to-one mapping but if at
all you remember
we could go and add multiple
dependencies for the projects that i set
in
just to give an example let's say if i
go to my first job i can do a
configuration here
and nothing stops me from triggering
multiple jobs after this by giving me a
comma
i can trigger multiple jobs here in case
if i have to run few things parallely
this also gives me that option to do
that but having said that this was the
most primitive way
in which the jobs were kind of
visualized and run
prior to jenkins 2.0 now this feature
became
such an important feature the users
wanted more and more
complicated because the pipelines were a
lot complicated it was not just one job
after the other there were multiple job
that has to be run
and there is also an introduction of the
jenkins agents
where multiple tasks could be parallel
run on different agents
so they wanted to club all of that and
the pipeline could have
all the such complicated stuff that's
where in post jenkin 2.0 or
in jenkins 2.0 jenkins released a
version
which has got the feature of pipeline
which can be written in groovy scripts
now groovy
is wonderful scripting language it's
very very powerful anybody can visualize
your pipeline or write your pipeline
using programming language and the point
of
everything as code where this whole
groovy script gets into your source code
repository so instead of putting jobs
here
and in case my jenkins kind of fails
you know there's a crash on my jenkins i
don't get back these jobs how do i bring
back
all these jobs back so everything has
code that's the devops principle
so the pipelines will be written as
scripts that is what i'm going to do
in my next exercise in my previous
example i showed you
the crude way in my opinion of putting
up a jenkins pipeline
but this is what existed prior to
jenkins 2.0
and now i have post jenkins 2.0 in terms
of my version jenkins version is 2.107.
so this supports something called as a
scripted pipeline wherein you can write
your pipeline
in terms of groovy scripts no need to
put up any jobs here
and remember how exactly you put up
these individual jobs you can write a
pipeline script in terms of groovy
language let me quickly show you
a very very simple and elementary
pipeline that i have
this is what a groovy script would look
like pipeline any agent can run this
stages there are individual stages that
is defined as a subset of these stages
so the first stage is the compile stage
and stage has got some steps in it
you can have multiple steps in it and
once only after all these steps
successfully complete
that's when the stage gets through
perfectly with the pass
so there's a compile a stage there's a j
unit stage
there's a quality gate stage there's a
deploy stage and i'm really not doing
anything much within this other than
echoing you know some text within each
of these stages
and what's interesting is at the end
there's something called as a post
which is similar to or you can kind of
equate that to what would be there in a
try catch kind of a block
supposed always meaning this would run
all the time
success only if at all all the steps
that were above in terms of the stages
they were completed successfully without
any failures
so typically you would have your email
that is going out here saying that the
build is successful and stuff like that
failure
if something went bad if any of the step
resulted in a failure this particular
block will get executed
unstable whenever any build is marked
unstable if at all only few things that
failed within your test run
and you would want to mark the build as
unstable are changed this is an
interesting option
so this compares the present run with
the previous run and if there's any
change
meaning if the previous run was a
failure and the present run is a success
or vice versa this would get triggered
so this is what a simple pipeline
script would look like so let me copy
this pipeline and let me put up a simple
job for running this pipeline so let me
open up my jenkins say a
new i would say scripted pipeline yeah
this is what i want
i don't want to choose a freestyle
project this is going to be a pipeline
project
so i would say pipeline and say okay all
right this has got
far less options than the other jobs
that we put up so
general i don't want anything here i
don't want any build trigger
right so this is where i kind of i can
paste in whatever i had copied there's
also something called as a pipeline
syntax
or a syntax generator this is like a
lookup where
you can choose what you want to do and
choose the option that is specific to
those steps and you will get a pipeline
generated or a script generated for you
jenkins knows that you're not very good
at understanding these pipelines
so this gives you the sandbox kind of an
environment where you can check out
whatever you want to do as a part of
your pipeline and then
get the equivalent groovy script from
here let me look at this
in a bit later so for now i have my
pipeline syntax already copied
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
paste what i copied all right so this
looks good
okay i'm not connecting to any github
repository of any of that
i'm just running a very very simple
pipeline which has got some steps in it
and
it just compiles or rather it just puts
out some messages saying that these
stage completed successfully
and stuff like that so let me save this
and let me try to
run this scripted pipeline all right if
you see this you'll see each of those
steps going through and if at all i look
at the console output
compile successfully unit passed all the
stages passed there was a pass
the failures doesn't show up you will
see the messages
from our post or the try catch block
that i was mentioning earlier
so this is how one would put up a
pipeline and you also get to see the
visualized view of your pipeline
that says which stage run after which
phase how much time did it take and you
can click
on any of these and get into looking at
the
logs from that particular pipeline front
that was pretty easy wasn't it now let
me
give you another scenario for a pipeline
wherein the source code of my pipeline
would be in a github repository
and i will write scripts to grab this
particular code
and run some part of the code which is
there as a part of the repository
so let me look at the repository that i
have i have a repository out here on the
simply learn github account which is
called the pipeline script
and if you see in there there are a
bunch of batch files that are there
so the first batch file would be a
build.batch so there's nothing in it
except that it is just trying to build a
particular project you can visualize
this
as individual batch files which actually
contain the scripts for
building running deploying and checking
the quality gate of your
particular project so i have a couple of
batch files that is here
and this is on the github repository so
i would need to write
jenkins job which will log into my
github account and then
check out this particular repository
from my account and then
run these batch files as a part of those
individual steps
within within the scripted pipeline so
let me
check as to how i could do that
let me put up a new project for this
let me call this scripted pipeline
scripted pipeline from
github all right so let this be a
pipeline project
that's good enough for me let me see my
scripts
all right now this is where i need to
put in the scripts for
pulling out the code repository from my
github server
and running those batch files that are
there as a part of the repository so
what i want to do is i already have
the skeleton of my pipeline that is
written which is very similar to
whatever was the pipeline syntax that i
showed you in the previous step so i
just copy this out here
and then paste it here so what i have
here is i've written on the
high level skeleton without really
putting in the actual steps required for
checking out rather or rather running
those build scripts so i've
got four steps one is the git checkout
step the builds tab
unit test quality gate and possibly the
deploy
all right so i need to put in the actual
scripts that is required for first
checking out the repository from my
github server so this is where i will
make use of this
pipeline syntax so as i mentioned
earlier
you have a bunch of help that is
available for you to figure out
the actual scripts that is required for
you to
write within your pipeline so what i
wanted to do is
check out something from git so it's get
related so search on git
and you'll find this option so i got to
specify my git
repository url and my credentials so
let me look at the repository url this
would be my repository url so let me
copy this
i'm going to copy the https url of my
repository
and branch is good and one thing that
you got to notice is for now
the repository is anyway a public
repository on github so even though if i
don't specify
any credentials that would work for me
still but in case you have a repository
which
needs strictly a username and password
to be specified you can kind of
add it out here using add jenkins and
you can give your username
and password out here but for now i
don't need any of these things
so i'm going to just say git checkout or
rather the url of my repository
and what we want is the master branch
for now i have only one branch on my
github server so this is good for me so
this is what
exactly i want to do as a part of the
script so if i click this
this is the script that i need to put in
my build script
so i come over here and this is what
will check out the code from my
repository all right so now
once i get my code onto my repository
from my repository rather
it will grab those code all these patch
files and get it onto my jenkins
workspace
now i'll have to run these batch files
as a part of each of my step
so let me look at what would be the
syntax so the first one
that i want to run would be my build.bat
all right so i want to run a batch file
all right and what is the name of the
batch file that i want to run i want to
run this build.bat
so generate pipeline script this is all
that i got to specify
as a part of my build step and then unit
test
i'm gonna just change this to unit
i think that's what i have in my
repository
okay that is unit and then deploy and
quality
queue capital quality and this one would
be
deploy
all right so this piece of code will
actually get into my repository and
check out my source code
and grab it and take it to the jenkins
workspace
so from this workspace since all the
files are there in the root directory of
this workspace
it will run these batch files one after
the other all right
let me save this and let me try to run
my pipeline
all right so it runs a lot of things in
the background trying to
get the source code from my repository
whoa whoa whoa that was fast
all right so it pulled out all the
source code from my repository
the last commit message from where the
source code was
pulled out it was this create deploy dot
bad
that looks good i'm saying building
checked out project
building the checked out project this is
what i've had in my
build.pad if i'm not mistaken okay
building the project that's what is
there with the timestamp
running unit test cases unit.bat it is
running unit.bat
and then giving me the date and times
time okay so all these kind of passed
and if i go back to the project i will
also see this beautiful
view of how exactly what is the time
that was taken for checking out the
repository
running the build.bat running the unit
test cases quality gates and all this
isn't that pretty simple now let me
modify my previous job or rather let me
put up a new job
for making use of an agent wherein i
could delegate
a job to an agent typically agents
can be brought up on any other remote
machines other than where your primary
engine can server is running
in case you don't know or you don't know
how to start up these agents
i would strongly recommend that you
refer to our previous
jenkins video on the simply learn
youtube channel
alright so let me just check the status
of my agent for now yes he's offline
so let me start this agent because agent
is not running
so i have the agent set up in my sql on
agents
so let me copy the script file that is
required for starting my agent
let me go to the agents folder open up a
command prompt
and let me try to bring up my agent all
right so the agent is up and running
for now i don't have the luxury of
starting my agent on a different machine
so my agent is running on my same
machine
but the agent's workspace is sql agent
while my primary jenkins server is
running
has the workspace out here c colon
program files
86 and this is the workspace of my
jenkins
all right i hope you can kind of
differentiate those two all right so now
what i want is i look at the same
job that i put in earlier or rather
modify that let the steps be the same
but i don't want to run that on my
master
server let me try to delegate that using
the script
so let me put up an agent
scripted job all right it will be
a pipeline rep job let's say okay
and let me copy this was a step that i
had put in for my previous job
so agent any so what i'm gonna do now is
i don't want this to be running on any
other agent i want this to be running
on the agent whose label is
let me check what is the label of my
agent that is running
okay so this is the name of my agent
okay windows note
so let me just copy that there all right
so with a very subtle change
instead of saying agent any i'm going to
run or rather i'm going to specify the
agent who will be running this job
is the one who has got the label as
windows note so this agent that i
brought on my
system has got the name as windows node
and it is configured to pick up any job
that
matches the label to which any job is
kind of delegated
so let me come back to my jobs where is
my scripted
agent job i've got
too many jobs running all right so this
is my agent scripted job that i left
halfway through
so here in the pipeline what i'm going
to do is is
this is all i'm going to need so the job
remains the same git checkout is going
to check out from the same repository
run the batch files accordingly but this
change
is just to ensure that this job is kind
of delegated on the agent
all right so this would be my agent job
let me save this
and let me get back to the dashboard and
let me run it from here if you see this
you know the master and agent are both
idle as of now
let me try to run this agent scripted
job all right so the agent kind of
kicked in
and there's a job that was delegated to
the agent if i
look at what is there in the console
output he's pretty much doing
whatever was there as a part of the job
but the interesting thing to notice that
this is the new
workspace rather this is delegated to
the agent
and the agent's workspace is this
particular folder so this is where it's
going to get all this stuff
run the whole thing and you know the
flow is pretty much the same the only
thing is
this whole thing ran on the agent if i
need to check my
agent i would see the workspace out here
agent scripted job if you look at this
all the batch files are here
and this is where the job was kind of
delegated to run so with a very subtle
change
in in the scripting i can ensure that
the jobs are kind of delegated onto the
agent the pipeline job specifically as i
mentioned earlier
jenkins provides you two different ways
of writing pipelines
called the scripted and the declarative
the first one that was launched was the
scripted pipeline
this is heavily based on groovy
scripting since jenkins
ships along with the groovy engine so
this was the first script or the first
support for pipeline that was provided
by jenkins in
2.0 this needs a little bit of a
learning curve
since groovy is a wonderful script
understanding that may be a little
cumbersome
but then once you kind of master it you
can write really powerful scripts
based on groovy at a very high level
this is what a typical scripted pipeline
would look like
something called as a node node
represents the
agent or the actual box on which your
job would be running and then a bunch of
stages are put out with each of the
stage
along with the steps that needs to be
covered as the part of those stages
listed one below the other so all these
stages if they run peacefully then the
whole task is kind of
marked as run successfully since
understanding groovy or learning groovy
was a little tough for many of the
people
so this is a new one from jenkins where
it provides you a much
simple and friendly syntax for writing
pipelines
without really needing to understand or
without nearly reading to
learn some group scripting again there's
a very subtle change between these and
you there are a lot of
lookups for figuring out what is a
better pipeline for you to kind of
write but if you can figure out the
difference or if you can try to
find that particular piece of code which
kind of helps you out with your pipeline
either of the skips there's not really
any difference in writing or kind of
delivering your pipeline using either of
these
two methods all right so declare a
pipeline is something like this where
you have an agent you can specify the
agent label or if you can say agent any
it will pick up whatever is an available
agent and run the job
and then you have something called a
stages stages is nothing but a
collection
of stage and stage could have multiple
steps defined within this
so if any of the steps in any of the
stage fails then that particular
complete stage and the build is marked
as failure
so very subtle difference between both
these
two syntax but using either of these you
can write powerful
scripts for your pipeline now let me
come up with an example
where i'm going to at least demo one of
the feature
where you could run a master and a slave
job
in parallel so let me come up with a
demo for that particular
scenario let me put up a new job for my
parallel agent pipeline let me call this
and this would be a pipeline project
i don't want anything here let me look
at uh the pipeline script that i have
pipeline agent none stages and there's a
first stage
where this would be a kind of
non-parallel stage where there's a need
for you to
possibly pull out the source code from
one of the repositories
and possibly unit test it if all the
unit test cases pass
then possibly you want to deploy it to
one of the test environments that would
be what would be there as a part of the
non-parallel stage
and then you may have a bunch of tests
that could be run
and assuming that you know you have a
windows node you have a linux node you
have some other kind of an operating
system based node
you could run these stages in parallel
so for
just for demonstration i've just put in
two parallel stages
in parallel is the keyword that you're
going to use for running tests parallely
so i would say parallel stage test on
windows and i'm going to run this
in my windows note well i could run a
bunch of steps that i want out here
and then in the other stage or other
step what i want is
i will run something else on on my
master as long as this parallel
keyword is encountered jenkins will
ensure that these two stages are run
parallely
for now i have both these things running
on my same machine but assuming that
these were running on different boxes
you could kind of visualize it as these
two steps are going to be started
parallely
without really any dependency on each
other and then you could wait for the
test results
and then based upon whether both of
these steps passed or failed if one of
them failed then we could kind of mark
the build
accordingly so let me copy this pretty
pretty simple
script let me put this out here and now
let me save this out
and let me try to build this
all right there you go the stage will be
executed first this is a non-parallel
stage that's going to happen
then the task 1 on agent task 1 1 master
followed by
as i said since i have only one node or
rather one system one with
both these things are running
simultaneously you will not really see
a benefit of this but assuming that you
have couple of boxes on which you have
multiple agents running you
possibly want to run your selenium tests
on the windows box because selenium
brings up some of those
ui which needs a browser you could
possibly need some
regression test that could run on linux
boxes or linux agents
and then you can kind of break down your
tasks into multiple things that is
running on multiple systems at the same
time
and then collate all the results okay
one final thing
all right now i have all my particular
job or rather the steps required for my
pipeline put down in in terms of the
scripts and
this is saved in this particular job
that's not a good or recommended
approach so what i'll do is i'll copy
all of these
steps out here and then what needs to be
done
is actually let's say let me go back to
this repository
the most preferred approach is where you
create something called as a
jenkins file jenkins file and you paste
all the scripts that is required for
your pipeline now this is
in a true sense the devops approach
where i'm going to save this out
so if at all you have a pipeline defined
for your project
the best place to kind of put out your
configurations for the pipeline is
within your repository
so this may be a different project that
i was referring to but assuming that you
have your project
where you know you have to define your
pipeline instead of putting that as a
particular
job on jenkins and fearing that if
jenkins fails other jobs
there's a crash and then you lose out
your job configuration the best approach
is to
use a jenkins file put all the steps
that is required the try tested steps
that is required
as a part of your jenkins file and then
you can put out a job
that can pull the source code from here
as well as use the steps that is defined
in the jetkins file
so let me end up by putting up another
job which is a true jobs kind of a job
so i would say devops
pipeline and this is a pipeline script
and then i'm not going to say any of
these things i would say
the pipeline script is from the source
code management so my pipeline script
is already defined it is present in scm
so what is my svn i mean
what is my source code repository this
is my source code repository where i
already have this so
let me copy this url this is my url
i don't need any credentials because the
repositories anyway in public repository
that is all that is required
i would say and the scripted file it
automatically picks up jenkins file
all right so let me save this let me
build this
so that's the beauty of devops wherein i
have a pipeline that is defined and
instead of putting the pipeline
as a job because pipeline is nothing but
a configuration
the configuration is also checked into
the source code repository and any
changes to this pipeline
instead of putting that modifications in
the job these are all captured as a part
of my
repository so the changes are nicely
configured so that you know we know
who's done what change if getting your
learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
devops today is being implemented by you
know most of the major organizations
whether it's a financial organization
whether it's a kind of a service
organization
every organization is somehow looking
forward for the implementation and the
adaptation
of devops because it totally redefines
and automate the whole development
process
all together and whatever the manual
efforts you were putting
earlier that is simply or gets automated
with the help of these tools here
so this is something which get really
implemented because
of some of the important uh feature like
a ci cicd pipeline
because cicd pipeline is responsible
for delivering your source code into the
production environment in large duration
of time
so cicd pipeline is ultimately the goal
which
really helps us to deliver more into the
production environment
when we talk about from this perspective
now let's talk about that what exactly
is a cacd pipeline now when we go into
that part
when we go into that understanding so
cicd pipeline is
a basically continuous integration and
continuous delivery concept
which is used or which is considered as
a backbone of the overall devops
approach
now it's one of the prime approach which
we
implement when we are going for a devops
implementation for our project
so if i have to go for a devops
implementation the very first and the
minimum implementation
and the automation which i'm looking
forward is actually from the
uh particular ca city pipelines here so
cacd pipelines
is really a wonderful option when we
talk about the devops here
so what exactly is the pipeline term all
about so
pipeline is in series of events that are
connected together with each other it's
kind of a sequence of
the various steps like you know
typically when we talk about any kind of
deployment
so we have like you know build process
like we compile the source code
which enter the artifacts we do the
testing and then we deploy to a specific
environment
all these various steps which we use to
do it like manually
that is something which we can do it
into a pipeline so pipeline is nothing
but a sequence of
all these steps interconnected with each
other executed one by one into a
particular sequence
now the pipelines is responsible for
performing a variety of tasks like
building up the source code
running the test cases uh probably the
deployment can also be added up in when
we go for
the continuous integration and
continuous delivery there
so all these steps are being done into a
sequence definitely
because sequence is very important when
we talk about the pipeline so
you need to talk about the sequence the
same way in which you are working on the
development
and in a typical world the same thing
you will be putting up into a specific
pipeline so that's a very important
aspect to be considered now let's talk
about what is the continuous integration
here
now continuous integration is also you
know known as the ci
uh pretty much you can see that a lot of
tools are actually
named as ci but they are referring to
the continuous integration only
so continuous integration is a practice
that integrates
the source code into a shared repository
and uh it used to
automate the verification of the source
code so it involves the build
automations test cases automation so
it also helps us to detect the issues
and the bugs
quite easily and quite faster that's a
very early mechanism which we can do as
such if we want to resolve
all these problems now continuous
integrations
does not eliminate the bugs but yes it
definitely helps them
uh you know easily to find out because
we we are talking about the
uh automated process we are talking
about the automatic test cases
so definitely that is something which
can help us
to uh find out the bugs and then you
know the development can
help on that and they can you know
proceed with those bugs and they can try
to resolve those things one by one
so it's not a kind of automated process
which will eventually remove the bugs
bugs is something which you have to
recode and you have to fix it by
following the development practice but
yes
it can really help us to find those bugs
quite easy
and help them to remove now what is the
continuous delivery here so continuous
delivery also known as cd
is in kind of a phase in which the
changes are made uh
into the code before the deployment now
in this case what happens that uh
it's um something which we are
discussing or we are validating that
what
exactly we want to deliver it to the
customer so what exactly we are going
ahead are we are moving to the customer
so that's what
we typically do in case of continuous
delivery
and the ultimate goal of the pipeline is
to make the deployments
that's the end result because coding is
not the only thing
you code the programs you do the
development after that it's all about
the
deployments like how you're going to
that to perform the deployment so that
is a very important aspect
you want to go ahead with the
deployments that's right you can go
there and that's a real beauty about
this because
it's in kind of a way in which we can
identify
that how the deployments can be run or
can be executed as such here
right so the ultimate goal for the
pipeline is nothing but to do the
deployments
and to proceed further on that right
so when both these practices are placed
in together in an order so all these
steps could be referred as in complete
automated process and this
process is known as cicd so when we are
talking about
like when we are working on this
automation so in that case what happens
that we are looking forward that how the
automation needs to be done
and since it's in kind of a ci cd
automation which we are talking about
so it's nothing but the uh end result
would be like build and deployment
automation
so you will be taking care of both the
build and the test case executions and
the deployments as such
when we talk about as such the ci cd
here
the implementation of chcd also enables
the team to do the build and deploys
quite quickly
and efficiently because these are things
which is you know happening
automatically so there is no manual
efforts involved and there is no scope
of human error also
so we have frequently seen that while
doing the deployments we may miss some
binaries or some miss can be there so
that is something which is you know
completely removed as such when we talk
about this
the process makes the teams more agile
productive and the
uh confident here because um the
automations definitely gives a kind of a
boost to the confidence that yes things
are going to work perfectly fine
and there is no issues as such present
now why exactly jenkins like
jenkins is what we typically understand
are we you know uh
here and there that it's in ci2 it's a
cd tool so what exactly is jenkins all
about
so jenkins is also known as a kind of
orchestration tool it's an automated
tool which is there
and the best part is that it's
completely open source yes there are
some
particular or paid or the enterprise
tools are there like cloud ps and all
but there is no as such of offering
difference between the cloud base
and the jenkins here so jenkins is an
kind of open source tool
which a lot of organizations pretty much
implement
as a date itself so even if they don't
want to go um
we have seen in a lot of big
organizations where you know
they are not going for the enterprise
tool like cloud b's and all
and they are going for the pretty much
you know core jenkins software
as such here so this tool uh makes it
easy for the developers
to integrate the changes to the project
that is something which is very
important because
it can really help the teams to say that
how the things can be done and how it
can be performed over there
so the tools is really easy for the
developers to integrate
and that's the biggest uh you know
benefit which we are getting when we
talk about these
tools as such so jenkins is a very
important tool to be considered when we
talk about all these
automations now jenkins achieves
continuous integration with the help of
plugins
that is also a kind of another feature
or benefit which we get
because there are so many plugins which
is available there as such
which is being used and uh for example
you want to have an integration with
kubernetes
docker and all maybe by default those
plugins are not installed but
yes you have the provisioning that you
can go for the installation of those
plugins and yes
those features will start embedded up
and integrated within your jenkins
so this is the reason this is the main
benefit which we get when we talk about
the jenkins implementation
so jenkins uh is you know one of the
best fit which is there for building a
ci cd pipeline
because of its flexibility uh open
source nature
plug-in capabilities the support for
plugins and it's quite easy to use and
it's very simple
straightforward gui which is there which
can definitely helps us you can you know
easily understand and go through the
jenkins and you can grab the
understanding
and as an end result you will be able to
have a very robust tool
which using which pretty much any kind
of source code
or any kind of programming language you
can implement ci city
whether it's an android it's a not net
it's a
java it's a node.js all the languages
are having the support for the jenkins
so let's talk about the ccd pipeline
with the jenkins here now to automate
the entire
development process a ci cd pipeline is
the ultimate
you know solution which we are looking
forward to build such a pipeline
jenkins is our best solution and best
fit which is available here
so there are pretty much six steps which
is involved when we look forward for any
kind of pipeline it's a generic pipeline
which we are looking forward
now it may have like any other steps
which is available there
probably some additional steps you're
doing like some other plugins you are
installing
but these are the basic steps which is
there like a minimum pipeline if you
want to design
these are the steps which is available
there now let's see the first one is
that
we have the uh required java jdk like
a jdk to be available on the system now
most of the operating systems are
already available with the gre like a
java gre but
the problem with gre is that it's only
for the build process
it will not be doing the compilation you
can run the artifacts you can run the
jar files you can
you know run the application run the
code base but the compilation requires
the java c
or the java jdk kit to be installed onto
the system
and that's the reason why for this one
we also required the jdk
and certain linux commands execution
understanding we need to have because we
are going to run some kind of steps
some installation steps and you know
process so that's pretty much required
now let's talk about how do ca cd
pipeline with jenkins now first of all
you have to download the jdk
and uh that is something which is
installed so after that you can go for
the
jenkins download now jenkins dot io
slash download is the website is our
official websites of jenkins
now the best part is that there you have
support for different operating systems
and platforms
from there you can easily say that if
you want to go for a java
package like a war file tucker ubuntu
deviant centos fedora red hat
windows open sushi uh freebsd ganto mac
operating system
in fact whatever the different kind of
artifacts or different environment or
different uh
application you want to download you
will be able to do that so that's a very
first thing to start up on
you download the generic java package
like a war file
then you have to execute it you have to
download that into a specific folder
structure let's say say that you have
you know created a folder called jenkins
now you have to go into that jenkins
folder with the help of cd command
and there you have to run the command
called java hyphen jar and the jenkins
dot bar there
so uh these are the executables uh
artifacts
so uh var files can be easily executable
um
jar files raw files can be easily
deployed so just because
with the java command you can run them
you don't require any kind of web
container or application container
as such so here also you can see that we
are running the java command and it
runs the applications as such and once
that is done so you can open the
web browser and you can open like
localhost caller edt
so jenkins uses the 80d port just like a
tomcat apache
so uh if you know once the deployment is
done
installation is done so you can just
open the localhost colony
now if you want to get the jenkins up
and running in the browser
probably you can you know go through the
uh public ipad address also there
so you can put the public ipad is
calling 880 and that can also help you
to you know start accessing the jenkins
application
now in there you will be having an
option called create new jobs so you
need to click on that
now once the uh particular new job new
item new job that's a
different naming conventions which is
available there now all you're going to
do is that you're going to do like
you are proceeding with the creating the
pipeline job
so you will be having an option called
pipeline job over there just select that
and provide your
custom name what pipeline name or job
name you want to
uh refer or you want to process there
now once that is available so what
happens that it will be an easy task for
us
to see that how exactly we can go ahead
and we can perform on that part
so this can really help us to see that
how a pipeline job can be created and
you know
performed on these modifications as such
now
when the pipeline is selected and we can
give a particular name that is this is
the name which is available
and then we can say okay as such over
there now you can scroll down
and find the pipeline section so there
what happens that
when you go over there and say that okay
this is the way that how the pipelines
are managed and you know those kind of
things
so you will scroll down and find the
pipeline section and
go with that pipeline script now when
you select that option
there are different options which is
available like how you want to manage
these pipelines
now you are you know have the direct
access also
like if you want to directly uh create
the uh create a pipeline scape you can
do that
if you feel that you want to manage like
you want to retrieve the
jenkins files also scored management
tool also can be used there so you can
work on that also
so like this there are so many a variety
of things which is available
like which you can use to work around
that how exactly the pipeline job can be
created so
either you can fetch it from the source
code management tool uh
like gate version or something like that
or you can directly put the pipeline
code as such over there
right now so next thing is that we can
configure and execute a pipeline job
with the direct script so uh we can once
the pipeline is selected
so you can put the uh particular script
like jenkins file
into your uh particular github link so
you
you may be having like already a github
link so that the where the jenkins file
is there so you can make use of that
now once you process the github link so
what we can do is that we can proceed
with that
and uh once the processing is done so
you can do the save and you know you can
keep the changes and
you know uh it will be picking up the
pipelines you know the pipeline script
is added up into
the github and you know you have already
specified that
uh let's just go ahead with this jenkins
file pipeline script from the github
repository and proceed further
now once that is done so what next you
can do is that you can go with the build
now process
you click on the bill now and once that
is done so what will happen
that you will be able to see that how
the build process will be done and how
the build will be performed over there
so these are pretty much a kind of a way
so you can click on the console output
you will get all the logs that is
happening in the inside that
whatever the pipeline steps are getting
executed all of them you will be able to
get or you will be able to you know get
on that part there
so these are the different steps which
is involved as such
and uh the sixth one is that you know uh
yes
whatever the uh particular uh when you
run the build now you will be able to
see that
source code will be uh you know will be
checked out and will be downloaded
before the build and you can proceed
with that part
now later on if you want to change the
url of this github you can configure the
job again
the existing job and you can change that
url github link url
whenever you require you can also clone
this uh job whenever you go ahead and
you work on that
and that's also kind of you know the
best part which is available as such
right and uh then you can have the
advanced
settings over there so in there you can
put like your github repository you can
say like okay
uh the github repository is there so i'm
just going to put this url
and you know with that what will happen
that the settings will be available
there
and the jenkins file will be downloaded
as such
and when you run the build now you will
be able to have a lot of steps like a
lot of
configurations going on so uh then
the checkout icm so we can have a
declaration like checkout sm which is
there so when the checkout sm is there
so it will check out a specific source
code
after that you go to the log and you
will be able to see that each and every
stage which is being built up and
executed as such okay
so now we are going to talk about a demo
here so on the pipeline here
so this is the jenkins portal now you
can see here that there is an option
called create a job
you can either click on the new item or
you can click on the new uh
uh create a job here now here i'm going
to say like
a pipeline and uh
then you know you can select the
pipeline uh job type here now you have
the free style pipeline
github organization multiplicity branch
pipeline these are the different options
which is available there
but i'm going to continue with the
pipeline here as such so when i selected
the pipeline
and say okay so what will happen that
i will be able to see a configuration
page which is related to the pipeline
now here the very important part is that
you have all the uh general build
trigger
you know options which is similar to the
free style but the build step and the
post build step
is completely removed because of the
pipeline introduction
now here you either have the option to
put the pipeline script all together
you can also have some particular
example for example let's talk about
some github
maven uh particular uh tool here so you
can see that
uh we have you know got some steps as
such over here and you know it's pretty
much running over there
now you run it it will work smoothly it
will check out some source code
but how we are going to integrate like
the version the jenkins file into the
version control system because that's
the ideal approach we should be
following when we create a pipeline of a
ci cd
now i'm going to select a particular
pipeline from scm here
then go with the get here now in there
the jenkins file is the name of the file
of the pipeline script and i'm going to
put my
repository over here in this one now
this repository is of my gate
which is like having even built pipeline
which is available there
it's having some steps related to ci
with for the build and deployments
and that's what we can follow as such
over here now in this one
the uh if it is a private repository
definitely you can add on your
credentials but this is a public
repository
a personal repository so i don't have to
put any kind of credentials
but you can always add the credentials
with the help of add here
and that can help you to you know set up
whatever the credentials the private
repositories you want to configure
now once you save the configuration here
now what
it's going to do is that your it's going
to give you a particular page related to
build now
uh if you want to run if you want to
delete the pipeline if you want to
reconfigure the pipeline
all these different options are
available there so we are going to click
on the build now here
and when i do that immediately the
pipeline will be downloaded and will be
processed
now you may not be able to get the
complete stage view as of now because
it's still running
so yeah you can see that the checkout
code is done
then it's going on to the build okay
that's one of the step which is there
now once the build will be done so it
will continue with the next steps with
the next for the steps there
so you can also go to the console
output log here like you can click on
this or you can click on the console
output
to check the complete log which is
happening there or
in fact you can also see the stage wise
logs also
because that is also very important when
you go for the complete logs
uh it may you know have a lot of steps
involved and you know a lot of logs will
be available there
but if you want to see a specific log of
a specific stage
that's where this comes into the picture
and as you can see that all the
different uh steps like test cases
executions
the scenar cube analysis the archive
artifacts deployment
and in fact the notification so all this
is a part of a complete pipeline
this whole pipeline is done here and you
know you get a kind of a stage view
it's success over here and the artifacts
is also available
to download so you can download this war
file is a web applications
as such over here so this is what our
typical
pipeline looks like that how the
automation the complete automations
really looks like as such over here now
this is a very important aspect because
it really helps us to understand that
how the pipelines can be configured can
be done
and pretty much with the same steps you
will be able to automate any kind of
pipelines
as such so that was the demo to build a
simple pipeline as such with the jenkins
and pretty much in this one we
understood that how exactly the cic
pipelines can be configured
and we can use them and we can get hold
on that part hello
and welcome to continuous integration
tutorial using jenkins
my name is chidanand and i am with the
simply learn team
today let's get started with jenkins
jenkins in my opinion
is one of the most popular continuous
integration servers of recent times
what began as a hobby project by a
developer working for
sun microsystems way back in early or
mid 2000s
has gradually and eventually evolved
into a very very powerful
and robust automation servers it has a
wide adoption
since it is released under mit license
and is almost free to use
jenkins has a vast developer community
that supports it by writing
all kinds of plugins plugins is the
heart and soul of jenkins
because using plugins one can connect
jenkins to anything and everything under
the sun
with that introduction let's get into
what all will be covered as a part of
this tutorial
i will get into some of the
prerequisites required for installing
jenkins post which
i will go ahead and install jenkins on a
windows box
there are few first time configuration
that needs to be done and i will be
covering those as well
so once i have jenkins installed and
configured properly
i will get into the user administrative
part i create few users
and i will use some plugins for setting
up various kinds of access permissions
for these users i will also put in some
freestyle jobs
freestyle job is nothing but a very very
simple job and i will also show you
the powerfulness of jenkins by
scheduling this particular job to run
based upon time schedule i will also
connect jenkins with
github github is our source code where
source code repository where i've got
some repositories put up there
so using jenkins i will connect to
github pull up a repository that is
existing on github onto the jenkins box
and run few commands
to build this particular repository that
is pulled from github
sending out emails is a very very
important configurations of
jenkins or any other continuous
integration server for that matter
whenever there is any notifications that
has to be sent out as a part of either a
build going bad or built being good or
built being propagated to some
environment and all these scenarios
you would need the contains integration
servers to be sending out notifications
so i will get into a little bit details
of how to configure
jenkins for sending out emails i will
also get into
a scenario where i will have a web
application a maven based
java web application which will be
pulled from a github repository and i
will deploy it
onto a tomcat server the tomcat server
will be locally running on my system
eventually i will get into one other
very very important topic
which is the master slave configuration
it's a very very important and
pretty interesting topic where
distributed builds is achieved using a
master slave configuration so i will
bring up a slave
i will connect the slave with the master
and i will also put in a job
and kind of delegate that particular job
to the slave
configuration finally i will let you
know how to use some plugins
to backup your jenkins so jenkins has
got a lot of useful information set up
on it
in terms of the build environments in
terms of workspace all this can be very
very easily backed up using a plugin
so this is what i'm going to be covering
as a part of this tutorial
jenkins is a web application that is
written in java and there are various
ways in which you can use
and install jenkins i have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
jenkins is usually installed on
any system the topmost one is as a
windows or a linux based services
so if at all you have windows like the
way i have and i'm going to use this
mechanism for this demo
so i would download a msi installer that
is specific to jenkins
and install this service so whenever i
install it as a service it goes ahead
and nicely installs
all that is required for my jenkins and
i have a service
that can be started or stopped based
upon my need any flavor of linux as well
one other way of running jenkins is
downloading this generic warp file and
as long as you have jdk installed you
can launch this war file
by the command opening up a command
prompt or shell prompt referral around
linux box
specifying java hyphen jar and the name
of this war file it typically brings up
your web application
and you know you can continue with your
installation the only thing being if at
all you want to stop using jenkins you
just go ahead and close this prompt
you either do a control c and then bring
down this prompt and your jenkins server
would be down
other older versions of jenkins were run
popularly using this
way in which you already have a java
based web server running
up and running so you kind of drop in
this war file into the root folder or
the httpd root folder of your web server
so jenkins would explode and kind of
bring up your application
all user credentials or user
administration is all taken care of by
the apache or the tomcat server or the
web server on which jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running
but still some people use it because if
they don't want to maintain two servers
if they already have a java web server
which it's been nicely maintained and
backed up
jenkins can run attached to it all right
so either ways
it doesn't matter however you're going
to bring up your jenkins instance the
way we're going to operate jenkins
is all going to be very very same or
similar one with the subtle changes in
terms of
user administration if at all you're
launching it through any other web
server which will take care of the user
administration
otherwise all the commands or all the
configuration or the way in which i'm
going to
run this demo it is going to be same
across any of these installations
all right so the prerequisites for
running jenkins as i mentioned earlier
jenkins is nothing but a simple web
application that is written in java so
all that it needs is java preferably jdk
1.7 or 1.8
2gb ram is the recommended ram for
running jenkins and also
like any other open source tool sets
when you install
jdk ensure that you set in the
environment variable java home
to point to the right directory this is
something very specific
to jdk but for any other open source
tools that you've installed there's
always a preferred environment variable
that you got to set in which is specific
to that particular tool that you're
going to use
this is a generic thing that is there
for you know for any other
open source projects because the way
open source projects discover themselves
is using this environment variables
so as a general practice or a good
practice always set these
environment variables accordingly so i
already have jdk 1.8 installed on my
system
but in case you do not what i would
recommend is just
navigate on your browser to the oracle
homepage and just type in or search for
install jdk 1.8
and navigate to the oracle homepage
you will have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers
that is okay that you can pick up based
upon the operating system on which
you're running so
i have this windows 64 installer that is
already installed and running on my
system
so i will not get into the details of
downloading this or installing it
let me show you once i install this what
i've done with regard to my path
so if you get into this environment
variables
all right so i've just set in a java
home variable
if you see this sequel and program files
java jdk 1.8 this is where my
my java is located c
program files c program files
java okay so this is
the home directory of my jdk so that is
what i have been
i've set it up here in my environment
variable
so if you see here this is my java home
all right
one other thing to do is ensure that in
case you want to run java or java c from
a command prompt
ensure that you also add that path into
this path variable
so if you see this somewhere i will see
yes there you go sequel in program files
java jdk 1.8 pin
so with these two i'll ensure that my
java
installation is nice and you know good
enough so to check that to double check
that or to verify that
let me just open up a simple command
prompt
and if i type in java iphone version
all right and java c
iphone version so the compiler is on the
path
java is on the path and if i told i do
this
even the environment variable specific
to my java is
installed correctly so i'm good to go
ahead with my
jenkins installation now that i have my
prerequisites
all set for installing jenkins let me
just go ahead and download jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
jenkins
all right lts is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions
weeklies i would not recommend that you
try these unless until you have a
real need for that um long term support
is good enough and as i mentioned there
are so many flavors of
jenkins that is available for download
you also have a docker container
wherein you know you can launch jenkins
as a container but i'll not get into
details of that in this tutorial all
right so what i want is
yes this is the war file which is a
generic war file that i was talking to
you earlier
and this is the windows msi installer so
go ahead and download this msi installer
i already have that downloaded so let me
just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
jenkins instance
or other installer this is a pretty
maybe a few months old but this is good
enough for me
before you start jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that
there is a variable called jenkins home
this is where jenkins would store
all this configuration data jobs project
workspace and
all that specific to jenkins so by
default if at all you don't set this to
any particular directory
if at all you install an msi installer
all your installation gets into
sql and program files 86 and jenkins
folder
if at all you run a war file depending
upon the user id with which you're
running your war file
the jenkins folder there's a dot jenkins
folder that gets created inside the
user home directory so in case you have
any need wherein
you want to backup your jenkins or you
want jenkins installations to get into
some specific directories
go ahead and set this jenkins home
variable accordingly before you even
begin your installation for now i don't
need to do any of these things so i've
already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation
all right so this is my jenkins msi
installer i would just
i don't want to make any changes into
the jenkins configuration
c colon program files is good for me
yeah this is where
all my destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes i'm
happy with this
i don't want to change this i would just
say go ahead and
click installation
okay so what typically happens once the
jenkins installation
gets through is it'll start installing
itself and there are some small checks
that needs to be done
so and by default jenkins launches on
the port 8080
so let me just open up localhost 8080.
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of
the installation process wherein i need
to type in the hash key
all right so there's a very very simple
hash key that gets stored out here
so i'll have to just copy this path
if i told you running as a war file you
would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a jenkins station
so as a part of the installation it just
asks you to do this
so if that is not great it will [ __ ]
about it but
this looks good so it's going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation
so you would need to install some
recommended plugins what happens is the
plugins are all related to each other
so it's like the typical rpm kind of a
problem where you try to install some
plugin and it's got a dependency which
is not installed and you get into all
those issues
in order to get rid of that what jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended
so just go ahead and blindly click that
install recommended plugin so if you see
there is a whole lot of plugins which
are bare essential plugins that is
required for jenkins
in order to run properly so jenkins as a
part of the installation
would get all these plugins and then
install it for you
this is a good combination to kind of
begin with and mind you
at this moment jenkins needs lots of
bandwidth in terms of network
so in case your you know your network is
not so good few of these plugins would
kind of fail
and these plugins are all you know on
available on
openly or or mirrored sites and
sometimes some of them may be down
so do not worry in case some of these
plugins kind of fail to install
you'll get an option to kind of retry
installing them but just
ensure that you know at least most or 90
95 of all these plugins
are installed without any problems let
me pause the video
here for a minute and then get back once
all these plugins are installed
my plugin installation is all good there
was no failures in any of my plugins
so after that i get to create this first
admin user
again this is one important point that
you got to remember
keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it
all right so i'm going to create a very
very simple username and password
something that i can remember i will
that's my name and an email id is kind
of optional but it doesn't allow me to
go ahead
in case i don't so i just given an admin
and i got a password i've got i remember
my password
this is my full name all right i say
save and finish
all right that kind of completed my
jenkins
installation it was not that tough was
it
now that i have my jenkins installed
correctly
let me quickly walk you through some
bare minimal configurations that is
required
these are kind of a first time
configuration that is required
so and also let me warn you the ui is
little hard for many people to wrap
their head around it
specifically the windows guys but if at
all you're a
java guy you know how painful it is to
write ui in java
you will kind of appreciate you know all
the effort that has gone into the ui
bottom line you are a little hard to you
know wrap your head around it
but once you start using it possibly
you'll start liking it
all right so let me get into something
called as manage jenkins
this can be viewed like a main menu for
all jenkins configuration
so i'll get into some of those important
ones something called as configure
system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete jenkins instance
few things to kind of look out for this
is a home directory this is a java home
where all the configurations all the
workspace
anything and everything regarding
jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's probably show
up somewhere
up here on the menu number of executors
very very important configuration
this just lets jenkin know at any point
in time
how many jobs or how many threads can be
run you can kind of visualize it like a
thread
that can be run on this particular
instance as a thumb rule if at all
you're on a single core system number of
executors two should be good enough
in case at any point in time there are
multiple jobs
that kind of get triggered the same time
in case the number of executors are less
compared to the number of jobs that have
there to woken up
no need to panic because they will all
get queued up and eventually
jenkins will get to running those jobs
just bear in mind that
whenever a new job kind of you know gets
triggered the cpu usage and the memory
usage
in terms of the disk right is very high
on the jenkins instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors 2 for my system is kind of
good
label for my jenkins i don't want any of
these things usage
how do you want to use your jenkins this
is good for me because i only have a
primary
server that is running so i want to use
this node as much as possible
quite pretty each of these options have
got
some pair minimal help kind of a thing
that is that is out here
by clicking on these question marks you
will get to know as to what are these
particular
configurations all right so this all
look good what i want to show you here
is there's something regarding the
docker
timestamps git plugin svn email
notifications
i don't want that what i want the yes i
want this smtp server configuration
remember i mentioned earlier that i
would want jenkins to be sending out
some emails
and what i've done here is i've just
configured the smtp details of my
personal email id
in case you are in a in organization you
would have some sort of an email id that
is set up for a jenkins server
so you can specify the smtp server
details of your
company so that you know you can
authorize jenkins to kind of send out
emails
but in case you want to try it out like
me i have configured my personal email
id which is on my gmail
for sending out notifications so the
smtp server would be
smtp.gmail.com i'm using the smtp
authentication i have provided my email
id
and my password i'm using the smtp port
which is 465
and i'm you know reply to address is the
same as mine i can
just send out an email and see if at
all this configuration works again gmail
would not
allow you to allow anybody to send out
notifications on your behalf
so you'll have to lower the security
level of your gmail id
so that you can allow a programmatically
somebody to send out email notifications
on your behalf
so i've done already that i'm just
trying to see if i can send a test email
with the configuration that i've set in
yes all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your you
know your gmail
account in case you want to do that if
not put in your organization smtp
server details which are for the valid
username and password and it should all
be set
all right so no other configurations
that i'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so i come back to managing
kens okay one other thing that i want
to kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario look at it this
way jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server
it doesn't know what kind of a code base
it's going to pull in
what kind of a tool set that is required
or what is the code that is going to
pull in and how is it going to build
so you will have to put in all the tools
that is required
for building the appropriate kind of
code that you're going to pull in from
you know your source code repositories
so just to give you an example
in case your source code is a java
source code and
assuming that you know because in this
demo this is my
laptop and i've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because
i'm a developer i'm working on the
laptop but my continuous integration
server would be
you know a separate server without
anything being installed on it
so in case i want jenkins to you know
run a java code i would need to install
jdk on it i need to specify the jdk
location of this out here
this way okay since i already have the
jdk installed and i've already put in
the java home
directory or rather the environment
variable correctly i don't need to do it
git if at all i want the jenkins server
to use git
git is a you know command bash or the
command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server
so you would need git to be you know
installed on that particular system
and set the path accordingly gradle
and maven if at all you have some mavens
as well you want to do this
any other tool that you're going to
install on your system
which is your continuous integration
server you will have to come in here and
configure something
in case you don't configure it when
jenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it'll crib about it
that's good i don't want to save
anything managing
let me see what else is required yes
configure global security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default
it's the security access control is set
to jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know jenkins by default it uses
file system where it stores all the user
names which hashes up these usernames
and kind of stores them so as of now it
jenkins is configured to use its own
database
assuming that you are running in an
organization you would probably want to
have a you know some sort of an ad or an
ldap server using which
you would want to control access to your
jenkins repository
rather jenkins tool so you would specify
your ldap server details the root dn
password or the manager dn and the
manager password and all these details
in case you want to connect your jenkins
instance with your
ldap or ad or any of the authentication
servers that you have in your
organization
but for now since i don't have any of
these things i'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so i will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that
once i put in few jobs so for now let me
not get into any of these
details of this just be aware that
jenkins can be connected for
authorization to an ldap server or you
can have jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so i'm going to save
all this stuff
that's good for me so enough of all
these configurations
let me put in a very very simple job
all right so job new item you know a
little
difficult to kind of figure out but then
that's the new item so i'll just say
you know first job this is good for me i
just give a name for my job
i would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me
i don't want to choose any of that so
unless until you choose any of this this
particular button would not become
active
so choose the freestyle project and say
okay
at a very high level you would see
general source code management
build triggers build environment build
and post build
in case you install more and more
plug-ins you'll see a lot more options
but for now
this is what you would see so what am i
doing at the moment i'm just putting up
a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything
so i don't want to put in a very
complicated job for now for the demo
let me just put in a very very simple
job i'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first
jenkins job all right i don't want to
choose
any of these again there are some helps
available here
i don't want to choose any of this i
don't want to connect it into
any source code for now i don't want any
triggers for now i'll come back to this
in a while
build the environment i don't want any
build environment as a part of this
build step
you know i just want to you know run few
things so that i kind of
complete this particular job so since
i'm on a windows box i would say
execute windows batch command all right
so what do you want to do i would let me
just echo something echo
uh hello this is my first
jenkins job and possibly i would want
the date and the timestamp
pertaining to the job i mean the date
and time in which this job was run
all right very very simple command that
says you know this is my first job it
just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right i don't want to do anything
else i want to keep this job as simple
as this
so let me save this job all right so
once i save this job you know the job
names comes up here
and then i need to build this job and
you will see some buildings stay out
here nothing is there as of now because
i've just put in a job
i have not run it yet all right so let
me try to
build it now you see a build number
you would see a date and a timestamp so
if i click on this
you will see a console output if i go
here
okay as simple as that and where is all
the job details that is getting into
if you see this
if i navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
i was mentioning earlier regarding
jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular jenkins installation
is all here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here
all right so the workspace is where all
the jobs that i have created
whichever i'm running would be wrong
there will be individual folders
specific to the jobs that has been put
up here all right
so one job one quick run that's what it
looks like
pretty simple okay let me do one thing
let me put up a second job
i would say second job i would say
freestyle project
all right this is my second job i just
want to
demonstrate the powerfulness of the
automation server and how simple it is
to
automate a job that is put up on jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what i said earlier about
jenkins because
at the core of jenkins is a very very
powerful automation server
all right so what i'm going to do i will
just keep everything else the same
i'm going to put in the build script
pretty much similar to
second job that
gets triggered automatically
every minute all right let me do that
percentage date and i'll put in the time
all right so i just put in another job
called second job
and it pretty much does the same thing
as what i was doing earlier in terms of
printing the date
and the time but this time i'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger so a build can
be triggered
using various triggers that is there so
we'll get into this github
triggering or hook or a web hook kind of
a triggering later on but for now what i
want to do i want to ensure that this
job that i'm going to put in
would be automatically triggered on its
own let's say every minute i want this
job to be run
on its own so build periodically is my
setting
if you see here there's a bunch of help
that is available for me
so for those of you who have written
cron jobs on linux boxes you'll find it
very very simple
but for others don't panic let me just
put up a very very simple
regular expression for scheduling this
job every minute
all right so that's one two
three four five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that i'm
going to put in
and jenkins got a little worried and is
asking me
do you really mean every minute oh yeah
i want to do this every minute let me
save this
and how do i check whether it gets
triggered every minute or not
i just don't do anything i'll just wait
for a minute
and if at all everything goes well
jenkins would automatically trigger my
second job in a minute's time from now
this time around i'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see
it's automatically got trigger
if i go in here yep
second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42
1642 which is 442 my time that looks
good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this jog would be
automatically triggered
now that i have my jenkins up and
running a few jobs that has been put up
here
on my jenkins instance i would need a
way of controlling access to my jenkins
server
this is wherein i would use a plugin
called role based access plugin
and create few rules the rules are
something like a global rule and a
project rule
project specific growth i can have
different roles and i can have
users who have signed up or the users
who might create
kind of assigned to these roles so that
each of these users fall into some
category
this is my way of kind of controlling
access to my
jenkins instance and ensuring that
people don't
do something unwarranted all right so
first things first
let me go ahead and install a plugin
for doing that so i get into manage
jenkins and
manage plugin a little bit of a
confusing screen in my opinion there is
updates available installed and advanced
as
of now we don't have the role based
plugin so let me go to available
it will take some time for it to get
refreshed all right now these are the
available plugins
these are the install plugins right so
let me come back to available and i
would want to search for my
role based access plugin so i would just
search for role
and hit enter
okay role based authorization strategy
enables
user authorization using a role-based
strategy roles can be
defined globally or for particular jobs
or nodes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that i want
i would want to install it without a
restart
right looks good so far yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember
jenkins is running on a java using a
java instance
so typically many things would work the
same way unless and until you want to
restart jenkins once in a while
but as a good practice whenever you do
some sort of a big installations or
big patches on your jenkins instance
just ensure that you kind of restart it
otherwise there would be a difference in
terms of what is installed on the system
and what is there on the file system
you will need to flush out few of those
settings later on but for now these are
all very small plugins so this would run
without any problems but otherwise if at
all there are some plugins
which would need a restart you know
kindly go ahead and restart your jenkins
instance
but for now i don't need that it looks
good i've installed the plugin
so where do you see my plugin i
installed the plugin that is specific to
the
user control or the access control so
let me go into yes
global security and i would see this
role-based strategy showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role based
plugin so this is what i would want to
enable
because i already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part
in the sense that who can do what i'm
going to install i mean i've
already installed a role based strategy
plug-in and i'm going to enable that
strategy all right i would say save
okay now i've installed the role based
access plugin
i would need to just set it up and check
that you know i would go ahead and
create some roles
and ensure that i assign users as per
these roles
all right so let me go to manage jenkins
configure all right let me see where is
this
configure configure global security is
that where i create my roles
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins
so for now i've just enabled the plugin
i have enabled role based access control
and i would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular
jenkins instance so i would say first
manage rules
so i would need to create some roles
here and the rules
are at a very high level these are
global rules and there are some project
rules
and there are some slave rules i'll not
get into details of all of this
at a very very high level which is a
global role let me just create a
role a role can be kind of visualized
like a group
so i would create a role called
developer typically the jenkins instance
or the ca instance are kind of owned up
or controlled by qa guys so
qa guys would need to provide some sort
of uh you know limited access to
developers so that's why
i'm creating a role called developer and
i'm adding this role at a
global role level so i would say add
this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there
and each of these options if you hover
over it
you would see some sort of a help on
what what are these
you know permissions specific to so what
i want is like you know it sounds a
little
different but i would want to give very
very little permissions for the
developer
so from an administration perspective i
would just want him
to have a read kind of a role
credentials again i would just want to
view kind of a rule
i don't want him to create any agents
and all that stuff that looks good for
me
for a job i would want him to just
possibly read i don't want him to build
i don't want him to cancel any jobs i
don't want him to configure any job i
don't even want him to create any job
i would just want him to read few things
i would not give him possibly a role to
the workspace as well i mean i don't
want him to
have access to the workspace i would
just want him to
read a job or check you know i have read
only access to the
job run um no i don't want him to give
him any any particular
access which will allow him to run any
jobs view configure
yeah possibly create yeah delete i don't
want to read yes
definitely and this is the specific role
so what i'm doing i'm just creating a
global role called developer
and i'm giving him very very limited
roles in the sense that i don't want
this developer to be able to run any
agents
nor create jobs or build jobs or cancel
jobs or configure jobs
at the max i would just want him to read
a job that is already put up there
okay so i would save now
i've created a rule i still don't have
any users
that is there on the system so let me go
ahead and create some
user on the system that's not here
house configure manager cans
manage users okay let me create a new
user
i would call this user as yeah
developer1 sounds good
some password
some password that i can remember okay
his name is developer1
d at d.com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which i kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one
is a user that i have configured so
still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so
i would go to manage and gains i would
say
manage and assign roles i would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what i'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular i will find the
particular user
and assign him the developer role that
i've already
configured the role shows up here
i would need to find my user whoever
created
and then assign him to that particular
role so if you remember
the user that i created was one
i would add this particular user and now
this particular user what kind of a role
i want him to
have because this is the global rule
that had created
so developer i would assign this
developer one to this particular
global row and i would go ahead and save
my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user
by logging out of my admin account and
logging back
as developer1 if you remember
this role was created with very less
privileges
so there you go i have jenkins but i
don't see a new item i can't trigger a
new job
i can't do anything i see these jobs
however i don't think so i'll be able to
start this job
i don't have the permission set for that
the maximum i can do is look at the job
see what was there as a part of the
console output and stuff like that
so this is a limited role that was
created
and i added this developer to that
particular role which was a developer
role
so that the developers don't get to
configure any of the jobs because the
jenkins instance is owned by a qr person
he doesn't want to give developer any
administrative rights
so the rights that he set out by
creating a developer role
and anybody who is tagged any user who's
tagged
as a part of this developer role would
get the same kind of permissions
and these permissions can be you know
fine grain it can be a project specific
permissions as well but for now
i just demonstrated the high level
permission that i had set in
let me quickly log out of this user and
get back
as the admin user because i need to
continue with my demo
with the developer role that was created
i have very very less privileges one of
the reasons for jenkins being so popular
as i mentioned earlier is the bunch of
plugins that is provided by
users or community users who don't
charge any money for these plugins but
it's got plugins for connecting anything
and everything
so if you can navigate to or if you can
find jenkins plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins
whatever connectors that you would need
if you want to connect jenkins to
an aws instance or you want to connect
jenkins to a docker instance or any of
those
containers you would have a plug-in you
can go and search up if i want to
connect jenkins to bitbucket
bitbucket is one of the git servers
there's so many plugins that is
available
okay so bottom line jenkins without
plugins is nothing so plugins is the
heart of jenkins
for you to connect or for in order to
connect jenkins with any of the
containers or any of the other tool sets
you would need the plugins if you want
to connect or you want to build a
repository which has got java and maven
you would need to install
maven and jdk on your jenkins instance
if at all you are looking for a
net build or a microsoft build you would
need to have ms build installed on your
on your jenkins instance
and the plugins that will trigger ms
build
if at all you want to listen to some
server side web hooks from
github you will need github specific
plugins if you want to connect
jenkins to aws you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world
as long as you have the url which is
publicly reachable you just have a
docker plug-in
that is installed on your jenkins
instance sonar cube is one of the
popular
static code analyzers so you can connect
a jenkins build you can build a
job on jenkins and push it to sonar cube
and get sonar cube to run analysis on
that and get back the results in jenkins
all of these works very well because of
the plugins now with that
let me connect our jenkins instance to
github i
already have very very simple java
repository up on my github instance
so let me connect jenkins to this
particular github instance and
pull out a job that is put up there all
right so this
is my very very simple uh you know
repository that is there called hello
java
and this is what is there in the repo
there is a hello hello.java
application that is here or a simple
class file that is there
it's got just one line of system.out so
this
is already present on github.com at this
place and this would be the
url for this uh repository
if i pick up the https url this is my
https url
so what i would do is i would connect my
jenkins instance
to go to github provide my credentials
and pull out this repository which is on
the cloudhostedgithub.com
and get it to my jenkins instance and
then build this particular java file
i'm keeping the source code very very
simple it's just a
java file how do i build my java file
how do i compile my java file
i just say java c and the name of my
class file which is hello java
and how do i run my java file i would
say java and hello
okay so remember i don't need to install
any plugins now because
uh what it needs is a git plugin so if
you remember when we were doing the
installation there was a bunch of
recommended plugins so git
is already installed on my system so i
don't need to install it again
so let me put up a new job here it says
git job
let it be a freestyle project that's
good for me i would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some
echo kind of uh jobs we did not need any
integration with any of the source code
systems so now let me connect this so
i'm going to put up
a source code and git would show up
because the plugin is already
there svn perforce any of those
additional
source code management tools if at all
you would need just install those
plugins and
jenkins connects wonderfully well to all
these particular
source control tools okay so i would
copy the https url from here
i would say this is the url that i'm
supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password
so i'll have to specify a username
and password all right so i would say
the username this is my username
and this is my https
credential for my job okay so this is my
username and this is my password
i just save this i say add and then i
would say
you know use this credentials to go to
github
and then on my behalf pull out a
repository
all right if at all at this stage if
there's any error in terms of not able
to
jenkins not able to find git or the git
dot exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that
you know something is not right you can
just go ahead and kind of fix that
for now this looks good for me i'm going
to grab this
url what am i going to do this step
would pull the
source code from the github and then
what would be there as a part of my
build step
because this repository just has a java
file
correct hello.java so in order to for me
to build this i would just say execute
windows batch command
and i would say java c hello dot
java that is the way i would build my
java code and if i have to run it
i would just say java hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after
the repository contents are fetched from
github so java c
java that sounds good i would say save
this
and let me try to run this
okay if you see there's a lot of you
know it executes git on your behalf it
goes out here it provides my credentials
and says you know it pulls all my
repository and by default it will pull
up the master branch that is there on my
repository and it kind of builds this
whole thing
java c hello java and it runs this
project java hello
and there you see this is the output
that is there and if at all you want to
look at the contents
of the repository if you can go here
this is my workspace
of my system hang on this is not right
okay okay job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there
on my github repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on github repository
all right so this was the same program
that was here and
jenkins on our behalf went over all the
way to github
pulled this repository from there and
then you know it brought it down to my
local system on my jenkins instance
it compiled it and it ran this
particular application
okay now that i have integrated jenkins
successfully with github for a simple
java application let me build a little
bit on top of
it what i will do is i have a maven
based
web application that is up there as a
repository in my
github so this is the repository that
i'm talking about
it's called me and web app it's got it's
a maven based
repository as you would know maven is a
very very simple
java based build tool that will allow
you to
run various targets and it will compile
it will based upon the goals that you
specify
it can compile it can run some tests and
you can you can build a
war file and even deploy it into some
other server for now what we're going to
use maven
is just for building and creating a
package out of this
particular web application it contains a
bunch of things
and what is important is just the
index.jsp
it just contains an html file that is
there as a part of this
web application so from a perspective of
requirements
now since i'm going to connect jenkins
with this particular
repository git we already have that set
we only need two other things one is
maven because jenkins will use maven so
in order to use
maven jenkins would have to have a maven
installation that is there on the
jenkins box and in this case
the jenkins box is this laptop and after
i have my maven installed i also need a
tomcat server
tomcat is a very very simple web server
that you can freely download
i'll let you know how to quickly uh
download and install the
tomcat alright so download maven
first
okay there are various ways in which you
can kind of download this maven
there is zip files binary zip files and
archive files so what i've done is i've
just already downloaded
maven and if you see i've unzipped it
here so this is the folder
with which i have unzipped my maven so
as
you know maven again is is a one open
source build tool
so you'll have to set in a few
configurations and set up the path
so mvn hyphen iphone version if i
specify this
after i set in my path my one should
work and if at all i echo
m2 home which is nothing but the
variable environment variable specific
to my onenote it is already set here
so once you unzip my one just set this
m2 home variable
to the directory where you unzip your
mi1 also
just set the path to this particular
directory slash bin because that is
where your maven executables are all
found
all right so that's with maven and you
know since i've set the path and the
environment variable maven is running
perfectly fine on my system
i just verified it okay next one is a
tomcat server
download apache tomcat server
8.5 is what i have on my system so i'm
just going to show you
where to download this from this is
where you download tomcat server
and um i already have the server
downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
i just unzip it here
and it kind of has a bin and
configuration i have made some subtle
changes in the configuration
first and foremost tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080
since we already have our jenkins server
running on port
8080 we cannot let tomcat run on the
same uh
port there will be a port clash so what
i've done i have configured tomcat
to use a different port so if i go to
this configuration file here
there is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 8080
i've just modified it to 8081. so i've
changed the port on which my tomcat
server would run all right so that's one
chain second change
when jenkins kind of tries to get into
my tomcat and deploy something for
someone
he would need some authentications so
that he'll be alloyed deployment by
tomcat
so for that i need to create a user on
tomcat
and provide this user credentials to my
jenkins instance
so i would go to tomcatusers.xml file
here
i have already created a username called
deployer and the password is deployer
and i've added a role called manager
hyphen script manager hyphen script will
allow
programmatic access to the tomcat server
so this is the role that is there
so using this credentials i will enable
or i'll empower jenkins
to get into my tomcat server and deploy
my application
all right only these two things that is
required let me just start my tomcat
server first
so i get into my bin folder i open a
command prompt here
and there's a startup.bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes
there you go tomcat server is up and
running now this is running on
port 8081 so let me just check if that
looks good
so localhost 8081.
okay my tomcat server is up and running
that sounds good the user is already
configured on this
that's also fine so what i'll do as a
part of my first job my one is also
installed on my system so i'm good to
use maven
as a part of my jenkins so i will put up
a simple job now
i will say job
mbn
web app i call this freestyle job that's
good okay so this will be a git
repository
what is the url of my git repository is
this guy https url
okay that's this url i will use the
credentials the old credentials that i
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that i'm kind of
connecting into all right so now the
change
happens here where after i get this
since i said this is a simple maven
repository
i will have some maven targets to run
so the simple target first is let me run
maven
package this creates a war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever i
run this package it kind of
creates it it builds it it tests it and
then creates a package
so this is all that is required maybe
let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see if it
connects well
if there's any problem with my war file
or the war file gets created properly
okay wonderful so it built a war file
and if you see it all
shows you what is the location where
this war file was
generated so this will be the workspace
if you see this this war file was
successfully built now
i need to grab this particular war file
and then i would need to deploy it into
tomcat server again i would need a small
plugin to do this
because i need to connect tomcat with my
jenkins server
let me go ahead and install the plugin
for the container deployment
so i will go to manage plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that i would need
i will install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay it installed the plugin so if at
all you see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the target folder i would see
this web application
war file that is already built so i
would need to configure this plugin to
pull up this
war file and deploy it onto the tomcat
server
for deploying onto the tomcat server i
will use the credentials of the user
that i have created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um okay all this is good
so the package is good i'm gonna just
create a package that's all fine
now add a post build step
so after the war file is built as a part
of this package
uh directive let me use this deployment
to
container now this will show up after
you install the plugin
so deploy this one to the container now
what is that you're supposed to specify
you're supposed to specify
the what is the location okay
so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there
that will allow you to from the root
folder it will pick up the war file that
is there
so star star forward slash star dot war
that's good for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application
that you know under which it will get
deployed into the tomcat server i will
just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now i need
to specify what kind of a container that
i'm talking about
all right so the deployment would be for
this tomcat 8.5 is what i need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that i have
so this would be the url so the
credentials
yes i need to add a credential for this
particular
server so if you remember i had created
a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployer
okay so let me use that credential i
would say
i would say add a new credential jenkins
credential
the username is deployer and the
password is
deployer
so i would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the url of my
tomcat instance
so this is the url of my tomcat instance
so take the war file that is find found
in this particular
folder and then you know context path is
same in
app use the deployer deployment
credentials and get into this local host
which is there
8081 this is the tomcat server that is
running on my system
and then go ahead and deploy it okay
so that is all that is required so i
would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it
and looks like the deployment went ahead
perfectly well so
the context path was mvn web app so if i
type in this
all right if at all i go ahead into my
tomcat server
there would be a web apps folder you
would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the github server
it was built locally on the uh jenkins
instance
and then it was pushed into a tomcat
server which is running on a different
port which is 808.1 now for this demo
i'm running everything locally on my
system but assuming that you know
this particular tomcat instance was
running on some other server
with some other different ip address all
that you've got to go and change is
the url of the server so this would be
the
server in case you you already have that
you know if you have a tomcat server
which is running
on some other machine that's all fine
with a different ipa that's all good
enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed
that's the beauty of jenkins and
automatic deployments or other
deployments
using jenkins and maven distributed
build
or master slave configuration in jenkins
as you would have seen you know we just
have one instance of jenkins server up
and running all the time and also i told
you that whenever any job that kind of
you know gets started on the jenkins
server it is little
heavy on in terms of disk space and the
cpu utilization
so which kind of you know if at all
you're in an organization wherein you're
heavily reliant on
the jenkins server you don't want your
jenkins server to go down
so that's where you kind of start
distributing the load that is there on
the jenkins server so you primarily have
a server
which is just a placeholder or like a
master who will take in all the kind of
jobs
and what he'll do is based upon trigger
that has happened to the job or
whichever job needs to be built he
if at all he can delegate these jobs
onto some other machines or some other
slaves
you know that's a wonderful thing to
have okay use case one use case
two assuming that you know if you have a
jenkins server
that is running on a windows box or on a
linux one
and if at all you have a need where you
need to build based upon operating
systems you have multiple build
configurations to support
maybe you need to build a windows you
know windows based dot net kind of a
projects
where you would need a windows machine
to build this particular project
you also have a requirement where you
want to build linux linux based
systems you also have a mac you you
support some sort of an apps or
something that is built on mac os
you would need to build you know mac
based system as well so how are you
going to support
all these needs so that's where in a
beautiful concept of master slave or
you know primary and delegations or
agent and master comes into play
so typically you would have one jenkins
server who will just you know configure
with all the proper authorizations
users configurations and everything is
set up on this jinkin server
his job is just delegations he will
listen to some sort of triggers or based
upon the job that is coming in
he will if there is a way nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control a lot of other systems
and these systems may not have a
complete or there's no need to put in a
complete
jenkins installation all that you got to
do is have a very very simple
runner or a slave that's a simple jar
file that is run as a low priority
thread
or a process within these systems so
with that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the servers goes
down
your master would know that what went
down and kind of delegate the task to
somebody else
so this is the kind of distributed build
or the master slave configuration so
what i'll do
in this exercise or in this demo is i
will set up a
simple slave but since i don't have too
many machines to kind of play around
what i'll do is
i will set up a slave in in one other
folder within my hard drive so i've got
the c
drive and d drive my jenkins is on my c
drive so what i do is i would just use
my e drive
and set up a very very simple slave out
there i'll just show you how to
provision a slave
and how to connect to a slave and how to
delegate a job to that slave
let me go back to my jenkins master and
configure him to you know talk to an
agent
so there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what i'm going to choose is something
called as jnlp
java network launch protocol so using
this i would ensure that you know the
client and server talk to each other
so for that i need to ensure that i kind
of enable this jnlp port
so let me try to find out where is that
let me try this
okay yes agents and
by default this jlp agents thing would
be disabled
so if you see here there's a small help
on this so i'm going to use this jnlp
which is nothing but
java network launch protocol and you
know i'll configure
the master and server to talk to each
other using jlp
so for that i need to enable this guy so
i
enable this guy instead of making the by
default the configuration was disabled
so i make him random i make him you know
enabled and i say save this
configuration
all right so now configured or is made a
setting
for the master so that the jlp uh
port is kind of opened up so let me go
ahead and
you know create an agent so i'll go to
managed nodes
so if you see here there's only one
master here so let me provision a new
node here
so this is the way you know in which you
bring up a new node you have to
configure it on the server
jenkins would put in some sort of
security around this particular
agent and let you know how to launch
this particular engine so that
he can connect to our jenkins master so
i would say new node
i would give a name for my node i would
say windows
node because both of these are windows
only so that's fine i just give an
identifier saying that windows node
i would say this is a permanent agent
i'll say okay
so if you see the name let me just copy
this name here
with the description number of executors
since it's a slave node and both of
these are running
on my system i'll keep the number of
executors as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just
clarify this since i have both my
my master is running on my c drive c
drive program files 86
or hang on not 86 c colon program files
it is indeed 86 all right jenkins
so this is where my master is running so
i don't want the c drive what i'll do is
i'll use something called as
a drive i have another drive in my
system but please visualize this like
you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether
so i create a folder here called jenkins
node and this is where i'm going to
place my
or i'm going to provision my slave and
i'm going to run him from here
so this is the directory in which i'm
going to provision my
slave node so i'm going to copy this
here and that is the remote root
directory
of your particular agent or slave so i
just copied here
the label you know probably this is fine
for me
and usage how do you want to use this
guy
so i would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs
i will only build jobs with label
expressions that match this particular
node and so this is the label of this
node
so in order for somebody to kind of
delegate any task to them
they'll have to specify this particular
label so imagine this way
if i have a bunch of windows system i
name it as windows star
anything that says from windows i can
give a regular expression and say that
anything that matches windows run this
particular task there if i have some mac
machines
i name all these mac agents as a mac
star or something like that
and i can delegate all tasks you know
saying that start with whatever starts
with mac in this node
run the mac jobs there so you identify a
node using the label
and then delegate the task there all
right so launch method
you know we will use java web start
because we're going to
we we're going to use jnlp protocol okay
that sounds good
directory i think nothing else is
required availability
yes we'll keep this agent yep online as
much as possible that sounds good
all right let me save this
all right i'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if i click on this node i get a bunch
of commands
along with an agent.jar so this is the
agent.jar that has to be taken down
to the other machine or the slave node
and from there i need to run this
along with a small security credential
so let me
copy this whole
[Music]
text here in my notepad
not bad plus plus is good for me
okay i copy this whole
path there i also want to download this
agent.jar
i would say yes
this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by our server
so all the details that is required for
launching this agent.jar is found in
this
uh sorry for launching this agent is
found is agent.jar
so typically i need to take this jar
file
onto the other system and then
kind of run it from there so i have this
alien.jar
i copy this or i cut this i come back to
my folder
my jenkins node i paste it here
okay so now with this provisionagen.jar
and i need to use this
whole command ctrl a control c
and then launch this particular agent so
let me
bring up a command prompt right here and
then launched it so i'm saying
in the same folder where there is
agent.jar i'm going to launch this a
particular
agent java hyphen jar agent.jar jnlp
this is the url of my server in case the
server and client are on different
locations or different ips
let us specify the ipad address all this
anyway would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your
jenkins or the slave node
okay so
something ran and then you know it says
it's connected very well it seems to
connected very well so let me come back
to my
jenkins instance and see you know if you
told me you see
earlier this was not connected now let
me refresh this guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision
jenkins node and then i copied all the
credentials of the slave.jar along with
the launch code
and then took it to the other system and
kind of ran it from there
since i don't have another system i've
just got a separate directory in another
folder
another drive and i'm launching the
agent from here
as long as this particular agent is up
and running or this command prompt is up
and running
the agent would be connected so once i
close this the connection goes down
all right so successfully you've
launched this particular agent
now this would be the home directory of
this jenkins node or the jenkins slave
so any task that i'm going to delegate
to this particular
slave would all be run here it'll create
a workspace right here
all right so good so let me just
come back and let me kind of put up a
new task here
i will say that you know delegate job is
good i say freestyle project
i'm going to create a very very simple
job here
i don't want it to connect to gate or
anything like that let me just create a
very very
simple echo
relegated to the slave
related to i don't like the word slave
delegate it to
agent put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am i going to ensure that
this particular job
runs on the agent or on the slave that i
have configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular slave
we give a label right so now i'm going
to put in
a job that will only match this
particular label
so i'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know windows label
run this job on that particular node so
we have only one node that's matching
this in a windows node
so this job will be delegated out there
so i save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this i just want to
demonstrate
how to kind of delegate it to an agent
so if you see this
it ran successfully and where is the
workspace
the workspace is right inside our
jenkins node it created a new workspace
delegated job it put in here so my old
or
my primary master job is in sql
program files under jenkins and this is
the slave job that was successfully
run very very simple but very very
powerful concept of master slave
configuration or distributed build
engine cans
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff
now we don't want this configuration to
kind of go away
we want a very nice way of ensuring that
we backup all this configuration
and in case there is any failure
hardware crash or a machine crash
we would want to kind of restore from
the existing configuration that we kind
of backed up
so one quick way to do that would be or
one dirty way to do that would be just
you know take a complete backup of our
colon program files colon jenkins
directory because that's where our whole
jenkins configuration is present
but we don't want to do that let's use
some plugins for
taking up a backup so let me go to
manage jenkins
and click on available and let me search
for some back there are a bunch of
backup plugins
so i would recommend one of these
plugins that i specifically use
so this is the backup plugin so let me
go ahead and install this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin so let me come back to my
manage plugins stop this plugin is there
so hang on backup manager
so you will see this option once you
install this plugin
so first time i can you know do a setup
i would say backup this particular
i'll give a folder uh this folder is
pertaining to the folder where i want
jks to backup some data and i would say
the format should be
zip format is good enough let me give a
name
or a template or a file name for my you
know backup this is good
i want it in verbose mode i don't want
to shut on my jenkins or should i shut
it down
no okay one thing that you got to
remember is that whenever a backup
happens
if there are too many jobs that is
running on the server it can kind of
slow down your
uh jenkins instance because it's it's in
the process of copying few of those
things
and the files are being changed at that
moment it's little bit problematic for
jenkins
so typically you back up your servers
only when there is very less load or
typically try to
you know bring it to a shutdown kind of
a state and then take a backup
all right so i'm gonna back up all these
things you know i don't want
to exclude anything else i want the
history i want the maven artifacts
possibly i don't want this guy i would
just say save
and then i would say back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps
and all the files that is required as a
part of
this is pretty fast but then if at all
you have too many things up on your
server for now we didn't have too many
things up on our server
but in case you had too many things to
kind of backup this may take a while
so let me just pause this recording and
get back to you once the
backup is complete so there you go the
backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users
and you know all that so all this is
kind of hidden down in this particular
zip file so at any instance if at all i
kind of crash my system
for some instance or say hard disk
failure and i bring up a new instance of
jenkins i can kind of
use the backup plugin for restoring this
particular
configurations so how do i do that i
just come back to
my manager cans come back to
backup manager and i would say restore
her that's an
or jenkins configuration hi guys welcome
to this video on jenkins interview
questions and answers
jenkins is a popular devops open source
automation server
it is used to automate the non-human
part of software development
and supports continuous integration and
continuous delivery
jenkins is a server based system that
runs in servlet containers
such as apache tomcat we have compiled
the most important jenkins interview
questions
that you might face in a jenkins or
devops interview
so without further ado let us get
started with jenkins interview questions
and answers
so the first question you'll be asked
about with jenkins is
explain a master slave architecture of
jenkins so the way that jenkins is set
up is that the jenkins master will pull
code from your remote git repository
such as github
and will check that repository every
time there is a code commit
it will distribute the workload of that
code and the tests that need to be
applied to that code
to all of the jenkins slaves and then on
request the jenkins master and the
slaves will then carry out
all the builds and tests to be able to
produce test
reports the next question you'll be
asked is what is a
jenkins file and simply put a jenkins
file is a text file
that has a definition of the jenkins
pipeline
and is checked into a source code
repository and this really allows for
three distinct
things to happen one it allows for a
code review and iteration of the
pipeline
it permits an audit trail for that
pipeline and
also provides a single source of truth
for the pipeline which can be
viewed and edited so which of the
following commands
runs jenkins from the command line is it
java
jar jenkins.war java dashwar jenkins.jar
java.jar jenkins.jar
java jenkins.org
and the answer is a java dash jar
jenkins dot war so when working with
jenkins you're going to be asked
what are the key concepts and aspects
of working with the jenkins pipeline and
you want to
really hold out your fingers here and go
through four
key areas and that is pipeline node
step and stay so pipeline refers to the
user-defined model of a cd continuous
delivery pipeline
node are the machines which is which are
part of that jenkins environment within
the pipeline
step is a single task that tells jenkins
what to do at that particular point in
time
and then finally stage defines a
conceptually distinct
subset of tasks performed through the
entire pipeline and
tasks could be build test and deploy so
which of the following
file is used to define dependency in
maven and do we have a build.xml
b palm.xml c dependency.xml
or d version.xml and the answer is
palm.xml working with jenkins you're
going to be asked to explain the two
types of pipeline used in jenkins along
with the syntax
and so a scripted pipeline is based on
groovyscript as their domain specific
language for jenkins and there are one
or more
note blocks that are used throughout the
entire pipeline on the left hand side
you can actually see what the actual
script would look like and the right
hand side
shows what the actual declaration for
each
section of that script would be the
second type of jenkins pipeline
is a declarative pipeline and a
declarative pipeline
provides a simple and a friendly syntax
to define
what the pipeline should look like and
then you can actually at this point
use an example to actually break out how
blocks are used to define the work
completed
in a decorative pipeline so how do you
create a copy and backup
of jenkins well to create a backup
periodically back up
jenkins to your jenkins home directory
and then
create a copy of that directory it's
really as simple as that
a question you'll be asked as well is
how can you copy jenkins from one server
to another well
there essentially there are three ways
to do that one is you can
move a job from one installation of
jenkins to another by copying
the corresponding job directory the
second
would be to create a copy of an existing
job directory and making a clone of that
job directory
but with a different name and the third
is to rename an existing job
by renaming a directory so security is
fundamental to
all the work that we do within devops
and jenkins provides the
center core to all the work that gets
completed
within a devops environment there are
three ways in which you can
apply security to authenticate users
effectively and when you are asked about
this question
of security within jenkins the three
responses you want to be able to provide
is a jenkins has its own internal
database
that uses secured user data from end
user credentials
b is you can use a ldap or lightweight
directory access protocol server
to be able to authenticate jenkins users
or c you can actually configure jenkins
to authenticate by using such as
oauth which is a more modern method of
being able to authenticate users
you're going to be asked how to deploy a
custom build
of a core plugin within jenkins and
essentially
the four steps you want to go through
are
first of all copying the dot hpi plugin
file into the jenkins home plugins
subdirectory uh you want to remove the
plugins development directory
if there is one you want to create an
empty file called
plugin.hpi.pinned and once you've
completed these three steps
restart jenkins and your custom build
plugin should be available how can you
temporarily turn off jenkins security
if the administrative user has locked
themselves out of the admin console
this doesn't happen very often but when
it does it's good to know
how you can actually get into jenkins
and be able to resolve the problems
of authenticating effectively into the
system as an administrator
so when you want to be able to get into
a jenkins environment
what you want to be able to do is locate
the config file
you should see that it's set to true
which allows for security to be enabled
if you then change the user security
setting
to false security will disable allow you
to make your administrative changes
and will not be re-enabled until the
next time
jenkins is restarted so what are the
ways in which
a build can be scheduled and run in
jenkins well there are four ways in
which you can
identify the way build can be scheduled
on running jenkins the first is
when source code management commits new
code into the repository you can
run jenkins at that point the second can
be the
after the completion of other builds so
maybe you have multiple builds in your
project that are dependent to each other
and when
so many other builds have been executed
then you can have jenkins run
you can schedule bills to run at a
specified time
so you may have nightly builds of your
code
that illustrates the changes in the
solution you're building
and then finally you also can manually
build
a environment on request occasionally
you will want to also
restart jenkins and so it's good that
when a question around how do you
restart jenkins manually comes up that
you have
the answers and there are two ways in
which you can do it one is you can
force a restart without waiting for
bills to complete by using the
jenkins url that you have for your
environment slash restart
or you can allow all running builds to
complete before restart
are required in which case you would use
the command of
the url for your jenkins environment
safe restart
with this we have reached the end of our
jenkins full course
we hope that you guys found it
informative and helpful
do like and share it thanks for watching
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here